die bundeswehr betrifft da sind wir
jetzt auch gespannt was im
koalitionsvertrag genau steht und wieder
an die koalitionäre sich genau
verständigen gehört das müssen wir jetzt
noch ein paar sekunden lang abwarten
hier sehen wir die koalitionäre die
natürlich den vertrag erst mal nur
geschrieben haben der muss dann noch
ratifiziert werden von den
entsprechenden parteien auf dem weg in
einer gewissen gelassenheit und
lockerheit manchen trick noch krawatte
mancher schon nicht mehr
genießen wo ich einfach mal die bilder
die uns eine neue regierung verheißen
und wie es aussieht einen neuen
bundeskanzler
schon mit entsprechenden gesten für die
presse
die raute kommt jetzt anscheinend nicht
zum einsatz
und jetzt jetzt rein in den westhafen in
einen convention & congress center
dort hat man diese
relativ
beeindruckende halle und hier ist
vielleicht sogar claudia roth zu sehen
wie es aussieht
da ist man schon ganz aufgeregt vor
allen dingen von seiten der
hauptstadtpresse ist man vor allen
dingen auch sehr aufgeregt weil man ja
einfach auch nicht viel weiß nun ist vor
wenigen minuten
der das koalitionsprogramm der
vertrag
herum geschickt worden ist also dann
quasi jetzt schon viral alle haben
versucht so schnell wie möglich dann
über 170 seiten zu lesen es gibt auch
sogar eine 1
kurzbotschaft mit kurzen spiegel
strichen um was es geht in der zukunft
bei dieser anstehenden regierung von spd
grünen und fdp jetzt müsste es
eigentlich jeden augenblick losgehen im
saal erhard scherfer ist für uns in
diesem saal und wird natürlich die
pressekonferenz sehr genau beobachten
und analysieren er hat vielleicht können
wir ganz kurz
in den saal schalten und gucken was tut
sich
ja große unruhe aufgekommen hier in den
letzten sekunden das heißt die überhaupt
protagonisten der pressekonferenz sind
angekommen hier in diesem event &
convention center im westhafen in berlin
eine ehemalige lagerhalle das ganze hat
auch noch schönen industrie charme
vermittelt dass man hier arbeit auch
arbeiten muss in den kommenden jahren
wenn man so will insofern natürlich
nicht zufällig gewählt die so location
ich schaue mal vorsichtig nach vorne da
sind zumindest mal die kamerateams schon
angekommen in der ersten reihe und haben
sich darauf gebaut vier pult haben wir
gesehen die letzten minute schon mit
jeweils zwei gläsern da kann man jetzt
wieder hochrechnen das ist was die
parteivorsitzenden
angeblich bei den verschiedenen parteien
natürlich einmal leicht irgendwie aber
offensichtlich muss da noch jemand
jemand mehr dabei sein bei diesem bei
dieser crew die dann da vorne gleich mit
der pressekonferenz beginnt schauen noch
mal zur seite
ist im moment noch nichts gesehen aber
das wie gesagt die kamerateams und
fotografen inzwischen schon da sind er
lässt darauf schließen dass hier nur
noch wenige meter von den beteiligten
zurückzulegen sind und was ich auch
schon gesehen habe vorhin dass die
hauptverhandlung runder der grünen auch
schon platz genommen hatte vorhin in der
ersten reihe mit ausnahme der beiden
vorsitzenden aber die sind ja auch
draußen gewesen was ihr noch fehlt sind
die hauptverhandlung aus fdp und auch
aus der spd die habe ich vorhin noch
nicht gesehen hier im saal und im moment
ist es damals dass vorne angeht auch
wieder ein klein wenig unübersichtlich
aber da wird wieder ein bisschen
hektischer der sich um die in eine und
andere sprecherin jetzt auf dem weg nach
vorne zeichen geben würde mal sagen dass
wenn ich die blicke richtig leute die im
moment in den hinteren teil des saals
gehen bzw auch nach außerhalb dieses
saales gehen
dass die beteiligten nicht wirklich weit
weg sind das ist ja immerhin schon mal
schöne nachricht dass die verzögerung
die sich einigermaßen in grenzen hält
das haben wir bei solchen
pressekonferenzen in der vergangenheit
natürlich auch schon mal ganz anders
erlebt aber diese koalitionäre diese
zukünftigen und die sich jetzt
verständigt haben auf einen wohl 177
seiten starken koalitionsvertrag haben
ja zumindest dass die
verhandlungsführung angeht und die
diskretion die dabei stattgefunden hat
und auch die ruhe in der das verhandelt
worden ist auch nach außen hin doch
einige überrascht irgendwie weniger dass
es überhaupt klappt sondern eher die art
und weise mit der das auf die das ganze
hier zustande wohl kommen wird es ist ja
immer noch unter dem vorbehalt dass die
parteien zustimmen müssen das wird also
am vierten dezember einen kleinen
parteitag einen digitalen der spd geben
im willy brandt haus und dann die
delegierten zugeschaltet von wo auch
immer die fdp wird einen kleinen
parteitag machen auch der dürfte
angesichts der korona lage er in einer
hybriden form stattfinden oder sogar
komplett digital und die grünen haben
einen gewissen vorteil bei der ganzen
angelegenheit weil sie von anfang an mit
dem plan hatten den koalitionsvertrag
online abstimmen zu lassen von ihren
mitgliedern nicht nur übrigens den
koalitionsvertrag auch eine information
die man gelegentlich nehmen wir mal
wieder einfügen muss sondern auch das
personaltableau das für die
verschiedenen ressorts vorgesehen ist
auch darüber stimmt die basis stimmen
die mitglieder der grünen ab in den
wahrscheinlich kommenden zehn tagen
morgen und ich es richtig in erinnerung
habe soll es losgehen das ganze wird
dann zehn tage dauern so dass man
ungefähr am 5 dezember dann auch mit
ergebnissen rechnen kann also im grunde
zeit danach geschah fast zeitgleich alle
drei parteien die voten ihres ihrer
mitgliedschaft haben um dann zu sagen
dass dann möglicherweise am folgetag das
wäre dann nikolaus dieser
koalitionsvertrag unterzeichnet werden
kann und dann am siebten oder achten
dezember im bundestag auch der neue
bundeskanzler gewählt werden kann mit
allem was dazugehört
auch der vereidigung des kanzlers und
der minister jetzt trifft hier ein im
saal auch die crew der spd so wie ich
sie benennen so dass sich hier von der
seite sehe also diese siebenköpfige
unterhändler gruppe in der tat die sind
jetzt auch hier drin und auch die fdp
ist mit dabei die werden sie dann auch
gleich weiter vorne sehen sie anreden
sich unsere länder jahr sehen wir die
drei generalsekretäre ich nenne sie
jetzt mal alle drei so ganz kurz noch
mal ein wort zu den drei
generalsekretären die ja doch
anscheinend eine sehr harmonische und
wichtige aufgabe erfüllt haben richtig
naja das ist klar die haben ja die
geschäfte in der hand gehabt sie haben
diese ganzen verhandlungen gemanagt sie
haben sie organisiert sie haben sie
organisatorisch vorbereitet sie an dafür
zuständig dass das ganze reibungslos
abläuft und ich würde aber sagen ich war
kann nicht sagen ob das leben einer
harmonisch gewesen ist da hab ich mir
durchaus meine zweifel denn wir haben ja
zwischendrin auch mal immer äußerungen
gehabt beispielsweise von michael
kellner dem bundesgeschäftsführer der
grünen gesagt dass es brutal anstrengend
gewesen sei diesen vertrag zu verhandeln
und man hat den einen und anderen dem
man mal gesehen hat dann auch durchaus
etwas
angegriffen sehen können und das ist
schon anstrengend irgendwie solche
verhandlungen über diese vier fünf
wochen die hinter den ligen aber das
ergebnis scheint ja so funktionieren
dass zumindest bei denen die verhandelt
haben große einigkeit darüber besteht
dass man es mit diesen 177 seiten mal
angehen kann in dieser zwanzigsten
legislaturperiode des deutschen
bundestag allerdings und das finde ich
ganz spannend die erfahrungen die viele
koalitionäre zu beginn gemacht haben die
sich dann über einen koalitionsvertrag
geborgt haben einen koalitionsvertrag
verfasst haben und dann im laufe der
legislaturperiode merken mussten wie sie
die wirklichkeit eingeholt hat wie sie
plötzlich probleme lösen mussten von
denen an die sie am anfang noch gar
nicht gedacht haben das hat diese
koalition jetzt schon mal von anfang an
in dem sie die verschärfte corona krise
die wir haben hier quasi noch parallelen
mit manager mussten möglicherweise nicht
immer ganz glücklich wie wir sie in den
vergangenen tagen seen haben
möglicherweise auch nicht immer ganz
einfach weil die zahlen ja dann doch
zusätzliche teilweise auch noch mal
explodiert sind und andere maßnahmen
erfordert haben als man sich das gedacht
hat und auch was die kommunikation
angehe nach außen anders als man gedacht
hat dass es nötig wäre also da hat
gleich schon mal diese koalition an die
erfahrung gemacht dass
regieren allein auf basis eines
koalitionsvertrages eben dann doch nicht
ausreicht weil die welt dann doch nicht
so einfach ist und noch nicht mal europa
und schon gar nicht die bundesrepublik
in diesem fall und die ganz konkret in
diesem fall die korona lage die
kamerateams sind immer noch um die erste
reihe geschafft von der ich jetzt von
hier aus meiner position aus nicht sehen
kann auch werden die kameras und
fotokameras und filmkameras da im moment
gerichtet sind womöglich die gesichter
er hat das können wir hier auch
ausmachen
strahlende gesichter alle gucken ein
bisschen wie gleich ertönt kinder der
weihnachtsbaum brennt und wir warten mal
ab was unter dem weihnachtsbaum liegt
das ist jetzt die situation wir warten
ab was im koalitionsvertrag drinsteht
wie es denn weitergehen soll mit
deutschland und das gerade angesprochen
dass die korona lage die haben wir jetzt
schon da muss man sich nicht noch
überraschen lassen von aber
bemerkenswert war das gestern abend die
bundeskanzlerin die noch
geschäftsführend im amt ist alle drei
parteispitzen
gerufen hat um zu beraten wie es
weitergehen soll das ist doch an sich
fair aber auch bemerkenswert oder
ja das ist interessant wie gesagt man
heutzutage so schön ein interessanter
move den die bundeskanzlerin daher noch
mal gemacht hat jetzt quasi auf die
letzten tage ihrer amtszeit dann noch
einmal handlungsfähigkeit und da die
dringlichkeit die bearbeiter bearbeitung
eines themas
signalisiert und das zu einem zeitpunkt
auch das hochinteressant von dem man
ausgehen konnte dass die verhandlungen
der ampelkoalition irgendwie in der
schule oft in der schlusskurve in der
schlussgeraden sind je nachdem wie man
das ganze sehen will also dass es
ja das in der tat bemerkenswert und noch
bemerkenswerter die entscheidenden
protagonisten sind jetzt angekommen auf
der bühne auf der kleinen bühne hier in
dieser halle
im berliner westhafen und ich denke die
pressekonferenz wird jetzt auch gleich
beginnen
des koalitionsvertrages von spd von
bündnis 90/die grünen und fdp kurz auch
ampel genannt den koalitionsvertrag den
finden sie auch auf den qr-code so dass
sie ihnen schnell auch hochladen können
und wir wollen jetzt ein bisschen
darüber sprechen fangen an mit olaf
scholz als kanzlerkandidaten
meine verehrten damen und herren
bevor ich zum anlass der heutigen
pressekonferenz komme möchte ich mich zu
einem sehr sehr aktuellen thema äußern
kroner ist nach wie vor nicht besiegt
leider
tag für tag ein und neue rekorde was die
zahl der infektionen angeht auch wenn
durch die impfung viele verläufen
deutlich milder geworden sind werden in
einigen regionen auch mehr mehr
infizierte in krankenhäusern aufgenommen
die intensivstation geraten mancherorts
an belastungsgrenzen
die lage ist ernst
die künftige bundesregierung hat
gemeinsam mit den ländern vergangene
woche entschiedene schritte veranlasst
um das pandemie geschehen einzudämmen
diese maßnahmen sind heute in kraft
entscheidend es nun eine konsequente
umsetzung der regeln zu 2g und 2g plus
im öffentlichen raum um die
infektionszahlen zu senken
nur wer geimpft oder genesen
gegebenenfalls über einen aktuellen test
abgesichert ist sollte zur veranstaltung
in restaurants und bars zutritt erhalten
so wie heute zu dieser pressekonferenz
am arbeitsplatz und im öffentlichen
verkehr gilt seit heute die dreijährige
um infektionen zu verringern
was für veranstaltungen
restaurantbesuche und bei der arbeit
gilt
sollten wir möglichst auch bei privaten
geht begegnungen selbst beherzigen
impfen und tagesaktuell testen um uns
und unsere lieben zu schützen
über diese beschlüsse hinaus wird die
neue bundesregierung des weiteren
veranlassen ersten
ständigen bund länder krisenstab im
bundeskanzleramt einzurichten er wird
die lage kontinuierlich gutachten und
beobachten und die umsetzung der
beschlüsse prüfen
zweitens
eine expertengruppe im kanzleramt
einzurichten die eine tägliche
beurteilung der korona lage vornimmt und
an die regierung gerichtet
darunter virologen
epidemiologen soziologen und psychologen
und weitere fachleute wir brauchen
diesen wissenschaftlichen sachverstand
um zu klugen erkenntnissen zu kommen es
geht darum die lage eng zu beobachten
die wirkung von maßnahmen zu überprüfen
und gegebenenfalls weitere schritte zu
entwickeln
drittens
dem kampagne weiter massiv voran zu
bringen und die kapazitäten der
impfzentren noch deutlicher auszuweiten
wir wollen mit mobilen teams in den
städten und regionen unterwegs seien und
auch ärzte und apotheken stärker
einbinden auch den einsatz der
bundeswehr im dienst halte ich für
richtig wir müssen impfen und boostern
um die verbreitung des virus zu
erschweren
viertens die beschlossenen impfung zum
schutz von wohngruppen müssen konsequent
durchgesetzt werden um zb alten und
pflegeheime besser zu schützen
für die besonders geforderten
pflegekräfte in den krankenhäusern und
pflegeheimen werden wir eine bonus
zahlung veranlassen die ampel koalition
hat sich darauf verständigt für diesen
pflege bonus erst einmal eine milliarde
bereitzustellen
impfen ist der ausweg aus dieser
pandemie in einrichtung in den besonders
wohlhabende gruppen betreut werden
sollten wir die impfung verpflichtend
machen eine ausweitung dieser regelung
bleibt zu prüfen
siebtens die mpk beschlüsse so
rechtzeitig zu überprüfen dass wir
gegebenenfalls weitere maßnahmen beim
nächsten treffen der ministerpräsident
und ministerpräsidenten der länder mit
der bundesregierung beschließen können
meine damen und herren ich
weiß wir hatten alle die hoffnung dass
dieser winter kein kroner winter werden
müsste doch trotz impfung sind wir noch
nicht durch wir müssen uns abermals
zusammen nehmen die hygieneregeln
beachten abstand halten und die masten
pflicht beherzigen um einigermaßen heil
durchzukommen
gemeinsam haben wir es in der hand diese
schlimme vierte welle zu brechen die
neue bundesregierung wird alles
erforderliche tun um unser land gut
durch diese zeit zu bringen
und damit komme ich zum eigentlichen
anlass für unsere pressekonferenz zum
abschluss der koalitionsberatungen
meine wichtigste botschaft dazu lautet
die ampel steht
spd grüne und fdp haben sich in den
verhandlungen auf einen gemeinsamen
koalitionsvertrag verständigt und damit
auf ein neues regierungsbündnis
diesen vertrag legen wir nun unseren
parteien zur abstimmung vor und wir
werben intensiv dafür dass alle drei
parteien diesen vertrag in den nächsten
zehn tagen zustimmen werden
unser ziel ist das erste bündnis von rot
grün und gelb auf bundesebene zu führen
eine koalition auf augenhöhe mit drei
partnern die ihre stärken einbringen zum
wohle unseres landes
und sein der glaube an den fortschritt
und daran dass politik etwas gutes
bewirken kann uns eint der wille das
land besser zu machen es voran zu
bringen und es beisammen zu halten
es geht uns nicht um eine politik des
kleinsten gemeinsamen nenners sondern um
eine politik der großen wirkung
wir wollen uns etwas zutrauen beim
klimaschutz beim umbau unserer industrie
bei der modernisierung des landes bei
der stärkung des gesellschaftlichen
zusammenhalts
wir wollen mehr fortschritt tragen
mit ehrgeiz und beharrlichkeit werden
wir unser land zum vorreiter beim
klimaschutz machen mit dem konsequenten
und zügigen ausbau der erneuerbaren
energien mit einer beschleunigung des
planungsrechts die industrie
unterstützen wir beim umstieg auf
klimaneutrale produktion
spitzentechnologie made in germany wird
es auch in zukunft geben
im wahlkampf habe ich viel über respekt
gesprochen ein respekt der eine menge
mit anerkennung zu tun hat aber dort
nicht verraten ich bin froh dass wir
miteinander vereinbart haben den
mindestlohn in einem schritt auf 12 euro
zu erhöhen wie ich es angekündigt habe
das bedeutet eine gehaltserhöhung für
zehn millionen bürgerinnen und bürger
wir führen die kindergrundsicherung ein
die armut verhindern und bessere chancen
für kinder und jugendliche schaffen wird
zugleich halten wir die rente wie
versprochen stabil und entwickeln sie
fort
und wir haben miteinander vereinbart im
kampf gegen hohe mieten den wohnungsbau
voran zu treiben
400.000 neue wohnungen pro jahr davon
100.000 öffentlich gefördert werden wir
bauen
die modernisierung unseres landes gibt
es nicht zum nulltarif
wir werden massiv investieren um
deutschland in der weltspitze zu halten
diese investitionen haben wir
miteinander vereinbart und dabei werden
wir die schuldenbremse einhalten dem
grundgesetz garantiert ist
ein souveränes europa ist der schlüssel
und für unsere außenpolitik als
wirtschaftlich starkes und
bevölkerungsreichen land im herzen
europas ist es unsere aufgabe diese
souveräne europa zu ermöglichen zu
fördern und voranzubringen
die freundschaft zu frankreich
die partnerschaft mit den vereinigten
staaten und der einsatz für frieden und
wohlstand in der welt sind die säulen
auf denen unsere außenpolitik fust und
nun lassen sie mich noch ein paar sätze
sagen zu den verhandlungen der
vergangenen wochen die sie ja eigentlich
von ferne verfolgen konnten wofür ich
mich nicht entschuldigen möchte
in diesen tagen und wochen haben wir eng
intensiv und mitunter leidenschaftlich
vor allem aber vertrauensvoll
miteinander verhandelt alle drei
parteien seien es die grünen angeführt
von annalena baerbock und robert habeck
die liberalen von christian lindner oder
die sp dem mit saskia esken und norbert
walter borjans alle haben diese
gespräche mit großem engagement geführt
konstruktiv und immer lösungsorientiert
angetrieben vom willen das land gut zu
regieren und es voran zu bringen
das hat mir gut gefallen und in mir das
gefühl verstärkt dass hier tatsächlich
etwas zusammen gewächse wachsen ist in
der koalition
die erste verkehrsampel ist im jahre
1924 in berlin errichtet worden am
potsdamer platz
damals zunächst noch eine ungewöhnliche
technik kann das funktionieren
haben die leute skeptisch gefragt
heute ist die ampel nicht mehr
wegzudenken wenn es darum geht die dinge
klar zu regeln und für die richtige
orientierung zu sorgen und dafür dass
alle zügig und sicher vorankommen
mein anspruch als bundeskanzler ist es
dass dieses ampelbündnis eine ähnlich
wegweisende rolle für deutschland
spielen wird schönen dank
[Applaus]
ich warte noch auf den applaus und dann
kann man verspätet also sehr geehrte
damen und herren auch von unserer von
meiner seite guten tag und herzlich
willkommen während wir verhandelt haben
olaf scholz hat eben den stil der
verhandlungen ein bisschen beschrieben
haben sich einige krisen dramatisch
zugespitzt und entwickelt die situation
an den außengrenzen in belarus aber eben
vor allem die korona pandemie und
während wir um worte oder interpretation
gerungen haben ist sorge und angst in
deutschland umgegangen menschen stehen
den schlangen warten auf die booster
impfung impfung und gehen dann
unverrichteter dinge wieder weg wir
übernehmen oder werden die regierung in
einer zeit der krise übernehmen und wir
sind uns und ich bin urlaub scholz
dankbar dass er das eben noch einmal so
ausgeführt hat klar darüber dass wir
alles notwendige tun werden um die
vierte welle zu brechen und die krone
pandemie beherrschbaren und zu halten
in einer zeit wo so viel sorge angst und
verunsicherung da ist es ist wichtig
dass wenigstens ab und zu ein zeichen
ein dokument in diesem fall des mutes
und der zuversicht gegeben wird und ein
solches liegen wir ihnen hiermit heute
vor
das leitbild dieser regierung ist eine
handelnde gesellschaft ein investieren
der staat und ein deutschland das
schlichtweg funktioniert
die viertgrößte volkswirtschaft der welt
die industrie stärkste nation europas
bekommt eine neue regierung eine
regierung die es in der konstellation
nicht gab die sich gefunden hat und
weiter finden wird
ein land in einer zeit der krise zu
modernisieren bedeutet eine große
anstrengung und eine große
entschlossenheit ist notwendig die
grundlage für diese anstrengung und
geschlossenheit die haben wir jetzt
geschaffen und im kern dieser neuen
geschichte die wir zusammen schreiben
können ist die vereinbarkeit von
wohlstand und klimaschutz wie ein roter
faden zieht sich der gedanke durch das
gegensätze durch eine neue politik sich
ergänzen können überwunden werden können
an massivsten wahrscheinlich zu
beobachten bei dem verhältnis zwischen
wohlstand und wachstum und dem schutz
des klimas und der natürlichen
ressourcen wir haben darüber gestritten
ob wir die klimaschutzziele in
deutschland die der groko dass bis 2030
die co2 emissionen um 65 prozent gesenkt
werden sollen noch anheben können und
haben uns dagegen entschieden dass in
den koalitionsvertrag reinzuschreiben
wir haben stattdessen einen anderen weg
gewählt nicht also immer größere ziele
zu beschreiben und zu ernennen aber in
der wirklichkeit immer hinter den
gesteckten zielen zurück zu bleiben
sondern konkrete maßnahmen zu
identifizieren wie wir die ziele
erreichen können solche maßnahmen sind
ausbau der erneuerbarer energien auf 80%
maßnahmen dass der co2 preis der
zertifikate nicht unter 60 euro fällt
was bedeutet dass der kohleausstieg
vorgezogen werden wird dass die
erneuerbaren energien nicht mehr ein
zusatz sind sondern im öffentlichen
interesse stehen dass sie die
versorgungssicherheit zu tragen haben
und nun haben wir nachgerechnet und
sehen dass wir mit all den maßnahmen die
wir beschlossen haben über die 65
prozent hinaus gegangen sind wir sind
auf 1,5 grad fahrt mit diesem
koalitionsvertrag der geist der dahinter
steht ist in der wirklichkeit zu agieren
in diesem fall natürlich erst einmal
einen leitfaden zu schreiben in der
wirklichkeit zu agieren und dann in der
gegenwart das bestmögliche zu tun auch
die zweite große ökologische krise
unserer zeit es adressiert wir haben das
artensterben und das höfesterben ist
schreit nach einem neuen denken in einer
landwirtschaftspolitik die nicht nur
wachse oder weiche kennt und was finden
wir in diesem chor beziehungs vertrag
die roadmap genau da hin zu kommen mehr
ökolandbau reduktion von pestiziden
förderung der bäuerlichen betriebe beim
umbau der tierhaltung und so versöhnen
wir den gegensatz von schützen und
nutzen durch eine neue politik sehr
geehrte damen und herren die wahl
christian olaf anna-lena
saskia und noch hat es war manchmal ganz
schön anstrengend
wir haben uns ganz schön viel zugemutet
aber wir werden eine regierung sein die
auch anderen menschen etwas zumutet also
müssen wir uns auch etwas zumuten die
entscheidenden momente bei diesen
verhandlungen
waren immer dann wenn man voneinander
gelernt hat nachdem man sich seine
programmpunkte vorgetragen hat und
gesagt hat wie continue so doof sein das
nicht zu verstehen das habt ihr schon
der 20 jahren gehört hört endlich mal zu
und die lautstärke wurde immer größer
gab es manchmal momente wo es gekippt
ist und man den hintergrund der
argumentation verstanden hat und dann
wurden neue lösungen möglich und so löst
sich vielleicht auch in dieser ampel ein
was wir für die gesellschaft beschreiben
gegensätze können überwunden werden
durch eine lernende politik ein
lernendes deutschland eine lernende
politik das ist das versprechen dass wir
uns gegen
[Applaus]
verehrte damen meine herren wir
übernehmen verantwortung für ein land
das in einer tiefen und noch nicht
überwundenen gesundheitskrise steckt wir
appellieren an alle menschen
sich impfen zu lassen oder sich um eine
auffrischung der impfung zu bemühen
ich bitte sie schränken sie in diesem
herbst und winter auch ihre persönlichen
kontakte
eingrenzen sie sie auf das was nötig ist
damit wir alle in diesen schwierigen
zeiten die freiheit der gesellschaft
bewahren und die gesundheit von uns
allen schützen können
das staatliche krisenmanagement der
künftigen bundesregierung
wird sich verändern es wird optimiert
aber es wird nicht weniger konsequent
sein um schaden von diesem land
abzuwenden
die gesundheitskrise ist eine aktuelle
herausforderung für die künftige
bundesregierung
aber wir haben auch bestehende
herausforderungen
denen wir uns widmen müssen
dekarbonisierung unseres lebens
digitalisierung des lebens die frage der
alterung der gesellschaft
das sind große aufgaben vor denen wir
gemeinsam stehen
wir spüren dass es in unserem land auch
den willen und den wunsch zur und nach
veränderung gibt
diese drei parteien haben in den
wahlkämpfen der vergangenen jahre ihre
unterschiedlichkeit nicht verborgen wenn
ich das einmal so sagen darf aber wir
haben uns in einem punkt
eine gemeinsamkeit erhalten nämlich den
status quo überwinden zu wollen wir
haben gemeinsam einen auftrag dieses
land zu modernisieren
insbesondere auch die junge generation
hat uns beauftragt diesen status quo der
vergangenen jahre zu überwinden
wir haben jetzt intensiv miteinander
gesprochen
die gespräche waren sehr diskret
außergewöhnlich diskret für die
politische kultur unseres landes der
letzten jahre ich versichere ihnen die
gespräche waren genau so kontrovers wie
sie diskret war
um einzelne sätze haben wir teilweise
stunden gerungen
sozialdemokraten und grüne können jetzt
stolz sein auf das was sie in diesem
koalitionsvertrag hineinverhandelt haben
das waren starke verhandler guten
argumenten ich glaube dass unsere
zukünftigen partner in der
ampelkoalition
in ihren parteien mit besten argumenten
für dieses verhandlungsergebnis werben
können für die fdp will ich sagen dass
wir auch unsere beiträge zum gelingen
leisten werden und dass die gremien der
fdp die heute über den koalitionsvertrag
beraten haben mit dem ergebnis ebenfalls
zufrieden sind was jetzt gebildet wird
ist eine regierung der mitte
die das land nach vorn führt
wir bilden eine koalition in der sich
die drei partner nicht begrenzen durch
das was unvereinbar in den programmen
war sondern wir erweitern und weil jede
politische kraft natürlich auch blinde
flecken hat wir sind also keine
koalition des ausschließen sondern der
komplementären politik
erreicht worden ist erstens dass
deutschland weiter anwalts solider
finanzen bleibt gerade angesichts der
sorgen vieler menschen um geldentwertung
ist dies wichtig es gelegt die breite
mitte des landes durch unterschiedliche
maßnahmen zu entlasten ohne dass es zu
belastungen an anderer stelle kommt
zweitens es gibt in unserem land so
viele private initiative privates know
how und privates kapital
das wir nun endlich entfesseln wollen um
unseren weg fortzusetzen in eine
dekarbonisierung digitalisierte
technologie nation die in der lage ist
wohlstand und wachstum für mehr menschen
zu organisieren
drittens wir werden diesen staat
digitalisieren
viertens wir bemühen uns in bester
anknüpfung übrigens an die sozial
liberale koalition der siebziger jahre
um die verbesserung der bildung und der
sozialen aufstiegs chance in unserem
land eines der versprechen der sozialen
marktwirtschaft dass dringend erneuert
werden muss fünftens wir stehen für eine
gesellschaftspolitische liberalisierung
vielfalt individualität
das verbindet uns
diese fünf punkte beschreiben
trendwenden wo wir neues wagen einen
aufbruch organisieren wollen
aber es gibt auch kontinuität dinge die
sich nicht verändern die uns gemeinsam
wichtig sind
die bundesrepublik deutschland wird auch
mit einer ampelkoalition
ein verlässlicher partner bleiben im
westlichen bündnis
in der europäischen union
und in der gemeinschaft demokratische
rechtsstaaten auf der welt
wir haben außerordentlich ambitionierte
vorhaben wenn sie den koalitionsvertrag
im einzelnen auswerten werden sie das
lesen wir haben außerordentlich
ambitionierte vorhaben und deshalb
spüren wir demut
angesichts der dimensionen dessen was
wir uns vorgenommen haben
diese demut ist ratsam angesichts der
herausforderungen wir werden diese
vorhaben auch nicht alleine umsetzen
können wir sind angewiesen auf die
unterstützung aus der gesellschaft aus
der wirtschaft und wir werden auch die
unterstützung derjenigen brauchen die
diese koalition nicht gewählt haben und
die sich zukünftig in der
oppositionsrolle wiederfinden
wir haben während der verhandlungen olaf
scholz neu kennengelernt
natürlich kannten wir ihn aus seinen
früheren staatsämtern
aus dem politischen meinungsstreit im
parlament zumal
wir haben ihnen aber neu kennengelernt
während der verhandlungen wir haben
ihnen erlebt als eine starke
führungspersönlichkeit
die über die erfahrung und
professionalität
verfügt dieses land eine gute zukunft zu
leiten vor allen dingen aber haben wir
seine innere haltung erlebt und muss mit
egon bahr zu sagen oder scholz verfügt
über ein inneres geländer
um aus einer klaren werthaltung heraus
dieses land nach vorne zu führen und
weit mehr menschen zu repräsentieren als
nur sozialdemokratisch grün oder liberal
gewählt haben und deshalb wird olaf
scholz ein starker bundeskanzler der
bundesrepublik deutschland sein
[Applaus]
meine sehr verehrten damen und herren
ist es okay bitte bitte
meine sehr verehrten damen und herren in
nicht einfachen zeiten schaffen wir ein
bündnis das anspruchsvoll ist dass sich
aber nicht versteckt vor den großen
herausforderungen vor den krisen sondern
die chancen in dieser zeit sieht und
deswegen haben wir in den letzten wochen
gemeinsam gerungen danke für das
verständnis
dass wir das wirklich intensiv gemacht
haben weil wir einen neuen aufbruch
vorschob fortschritt schaffen wollen und
uns in dieser zeit nicht leisten können
hinter mauern zu verstecken und den
kleinsten gemeinsamen nenner zu suchen
sondern wirklich in den entscheidenden
bereichen dieses landes ein
paradigmenwechsel einzuleiten
denn es braucht für die modernisierung
unseres landes für die modernisierung
unseres staates und vor allen dingen für
den zusammenhalt in unserer gesellschaft
und wir haben für die größte
herausforderung unserer zeit die
klimakrise
mit diesem gemeinsamen
koalitionsentwurf den wir jetzt unseren
parteien vorlegen
den weg dafür bereitet dass wir als eine
der größten industrienationen der welt
klimaneutral werden können und zwar
klimaneutral im herzen europas gemeinsam
mit unseren europäischen
nachbarn und freunden und so wie wir vor
20 jahren mit erneuerbaren energien
eine neue technologie in die welt
gebracht haben die nicht nur eine
technologie war sondern die die
energiepolitik aber auch die
internationale zusammenarbeit verändert
hat ist das jetzt ein paradigmenwechsel
wo wir die wirtschaft auch
klimaneutralität stellen können und das
gemeinsam als beitrag zu sicherheit in
der welt auf den weg bringen können und
deswegen haben wir einen
koalitionsentwurf geschaffen wo sich
diese frage der klimaneutralität durch
alle bereiche des koalitionsvertrages
durchzieht von der umweltpolitik über
die landwirtschaft die verkehrspolitik
die industrie und wirtschaftspolitik
aber eben auch die internationale
zusammenarbeit und außen und
sicherheitspolitik und das bedeutet auch
dass die frage einer gemeinsamen
klimapolitik eine europäische antwort
bedarf und vor allen dingen einer
aktiven energie und außenpolitik bedarf
um diese krise große menschheitsaufgabe
gemeinsam anzugehen und wir erleben
gerade dass wir diese gemeinsame aufgabe
in einer zeit angehen wo die krisen auch
um uns herum im direkten umfeld mitten
in europa schwerer werden wo die
herausforderung schwerer werden werden
wir die situation in belarus sehen wenn
wir die situation an den außengrenzen
europas sehen daher haben wir uns
gemeinsam darauf verständigt wieder zu
einer aktiven europäischen
außenpolitik
zurückzukommen die auf die stärke der
diplomatie und des dialoges setzt und
auf eine werte- und menschenrechts
geleitete gemeinsame diplomatie
ein anderer großer paradigmenwechsel in
diesem papier ist dass wir
nicht immer nur alles aus der sichtweise
von erwachsenen sehen sondern dass wir
eine regierung bilden für die vielfalt
unserer gesellschaft eine regierung und
das amt viele familien in unserem land
in dieser corona pandemie immer wieder
gespürt die auch die kleinsten und
jüngsten die kinder und die jugendlichen
die jungen menschen in unserem land
sieht und versteht dass kinder keine
kleinen erwachsenen sind sondern kinder
eigene rechte haben und
entsprechend sind hier projekte
verankert wie eine kindergrundsicherung
die ein wirkliches umdenken nicht nur
der sozialpolitik bedeutet in dem man
aus dem harz 4 system herausholen
eigentlich kindern ihr ein gehört haben
sondern indem man kinder und jugendliche
eine andere bedeutung in dieser
zukünftigen bundesregierung gibt und das
als beitrag zu einer
generationenübergreifenden
politik die nicht jede einzelne gruppe
für sich sieht sondern die vielfalt in
der gesellschaft als stärker begreift
und auch für die vielfalt dieser
gesellschaft gemeinsam politik macht und
da ist die konstellation die ja einige
von uns gerade schon angesprochen haben
dass wir auch nicht eine homogene gruppe
sind wo immer alle schon
wissen dass sie 100 prozent recht haben
sich zu 100 prozent durchsetzen nein
sondern in einer dreier konstellation
kann sich niemand zu 100 prozent
durchsetzen was aber eine möglichkeit
gibt auch mal den standpunkt zu wechseln
und zu verstehen dass wenn christian
lindner eine 6 auf der seite sieht und
welche einen neuen sehen dass wir
vielleicht beide recht haben können und
wir nur bereit sein müssen mal die
sichtweite des anderen anzunehmen und in
einer zeit wo soviel auch gegeneinander
und spaltung in der gesellschaft
vorhanden ist eine regierung zu bilden
die bereit ist im blickwinkel zu
wechseln und gemeinsam lösungen und
antworten zu finden bedeutet für uns
auch eine modernisierung des
gesellschaftlichen vertrages eine
modernisierung des
staatsbürgerschaftsrechts eine
modernisierung des familienrechts die
auf der höhe des einundzwanzigsten
jahrhundert ist und dafür schaffen wir
hier gemeinsam die grundlage und auch
von meiner seite herzlichen dank mischen
und diejenigen die hier auf der bühne
stehen sondern sie haben sich ja gefragt
warum wir in messehallen unter anderem
getagt haben weil wir eben die viel zeit
auch unseren parteien mit eingebracht
haben und mit hunderten von der
verhandlerin und verhandlern in
arbeitsgruppen gesprochen haben und auch
und denjenigen an dieser stelle
herzlichen dank genauso an diejenigen
menschen die sich in dieser schwierigen
zeit an uns gewandt haben und deutlich
gemacht haben unsere erfahrungen in den
letzten anderthalb jahren corona
pandemie die müssen sich in einer neuen
regierung widerspiegeln und das hat olaf
scholz eingangs gesagt auch dass es die
erste aufgabe dieser neuen ampel
konstellation
[Applaus]
meine damen und herren ich bin mir sehr
gewiss wir haben mit diesem
koalitionsvertrag etwas auf die beine
gestellt das diesem land gut tun wird
wir haben in vielen langen gesprächen
das ist hier heute schon zum ausdruck
gekommen zum teil stundenlang über
einzelne sätze gerungen worden ist eines
gemeinsam gehabt als
ausgangsvoraussetzungen und das war eine
gemeinsame fortschritts erzählung das
heißt wir müssen in diesem land
schneller werden wir müssen dinge
anpacken wir brauchen einen aufbruch und
zwar nicht nur ökonomisch und ökologisch
wir brauchen ihn auch
gesellschaftspolitisch und diese
gemeinsame grundhaltung hat uns in
diesen gesprächen getragen nun weiß
jeder sind drei parteien die mit
durchaus unterschiedlichen blickwinkeln
auf diese gemeinsame thematik gucken und
wir wollten auch nicht fusionieren wir
wollen calyon und deswegen war klar dass
man das gleiche große ziel mit
unterschiedlichen maßnahmen mit
unterschiedlichen instrumenten angeben
will und ich kann mich christian lindner
anschließend das haben wir nicht gemacht
indem wir uns mit unseren
unterschiedlichen instrumenten
gegenseitig blockiert haben sondern dass
wir uns gegenseitig bereichert haben
durch diesen blickwinkel um eben etwas
zustande zu bringen das am ende allen
menschen in diesem land und nicht nur
unterschiedlichen partei
anhängerschaften nutzen soll ich glaube
wenn man es jetzt mal übersetzt was
haben wir da gemacht dann muss man sagen
oder darf man sagen es geht vor allem
darum zu investieren privat aber auch
öffentlich in netze in
transformationen in
innovative projekte die uns voran
bringen digitalisierung und das ganze
eben immer in dem blick halten dass wir
es nicht nur mit der zukunftssicherung
zu tun haben sondern dass auch die
gegenwart der menschen betroffen ist als
die menschen mit kommen wollen bei dem
was sich ändern muss von dem wir alle
wissen dass sie sich aus ändern wird und
deswegen glaube ich auch wenn es dann
andere dinge gibt wo instrumente
die für uns eine größere rolle gespielt
haben so nicht am ende durch gekommen
sind ich sag mal eine stärkere belastung
ganz große einkommen und große vermögen
dann ist trotzdem gelungen dass wir viel
für kleine und mittlere einkommen haben
erreichen können gemeinsam erreichen
können ich nenne mindestlohn ich nenne
stabile renten ich nenne bezahlbares
wohnen und dass wir auf der anderen
seite auch klar gesagt haben das
gerechtigkeitsgefühl der menschen nicht
einseitig belastet zu werden hängt auch
sehr damit zusammen wie viel wir dagegen
unternehmen das sich andere vollkommen
aus der verantwortung stehlen wollen es
recht wenn es um steuerbetrug geht aber
eben auch wenn es um trickreiche
gestaltungen von steuern geht wir haben
über die mindeststeuer gesprochen wir
haben von der klaren einstellung zur
bekämpfung der geldwäsche gesprochen wir
haben und nicht nur gesprochen sondern
wir haben klare vereinbarungen dazu
getroffen welche institutionen wir
stärken müssen wir haben klar gesagt die
investitionen die wir brauchen kosten
geld dieses geld muss zur verfügung
stehen in dem wir die schuldenbremse
nutzen mit den möglichkeiten die sie
bietet indem wir andere institutionen
wie die kreditanstalt für wiederaufbau
oder förderbanken der länder und andere
nutzen um die investitionen möglich zu
machen und ich glaube wenn man sich das
gesamtpaket anguckt dann kann man sagen
dass dieser gemeinschaftliche blick auf
gegenwart und zukunft auf klimaschutz
soziale verantwortung förderung der lust
auf innovation in diesem paket enorm
drin steckt und dass das echt diese
gemeinsame leistung ist durch das
austauschen auch unterschiedlicher
positionen das ausfechten
unterschiedlicher positionen und wenn
ich noch mal auf die gegenwart nur zu
sprechen komme dann sind wir nun mal mit
diesen diskussionen mitten in einer
gesundheitskrise die wir lösen müssen
und deswegen möchte ich an dieser stelle
noch mal neben all denen die im
hintergrund und am verhandlungstisch
mitgeholfen haben zwei
ministerpräsidentinnen dann können die
hier vorne sitzen malu dreyer und
manuela schwesig die
ich finde in ganz wichtigen impuls
gegeben haben wie man runter kommt von
diesem was machen wir bei corona auf
zuruf sondern wie kommt man systematisch
dahin dass man wissenschaftliche
erkenntnisse und politisches handeln in
übereinstimmung bringt und dafür waren
wir alle gemeinsam das darf ich glaube
ich sagen den beiden sehr dankbar
gestern abend dass wir auf diesem weg
eben auch zusammen ein stück
weiterkommen das hat wollen die
bürgerinnen und bürger dieses landes und
ich glaube da zeigt sich auch direkt
schon im vorfeld welchen geist diese
koalition prägt welcher geist die
koalition trägt und auch eine bemerkung
nutzung schluss machen für mich ist das
ein schlusspunkt ich habe bin dankbar
dafür dass ich mitwirken konnte das wir
auch als spd in diese rolle kommen
konnten eine regierung zu bilden an
diesen regierungsgesprächen teilzunehmen
ich bin dankbar dafür wie wir zusammen
gefunden haben zu etwas was jetzt für
mich ein schlusspunkt aber für diese
regierung für das land ein neuer anfang
ist und deswegen bin ich sehr froh
darüber diese zwei jahre habe einsetzen
zu können und werde mich jetzt auf die
position beziehen dass ich sage jetzt
kam dann mit anderen gucken was draus
wird die guter grundstein dafür ist
gelegt und ich freue mich sehr darüber
dass das so gelungen ist vielen dank
[Applaus]
ja meine sehr verehrten damen und herren
unser zukünftiger bundeskanzler olaf
scholz lassen sie mich diese worte noch
mal genießen olaf scholz also hat ein
anderer stelle mal gesagt hier ist etwas
zusammengewachsen in den letzten wochen
was zusammen passt und ich finde das ist
eine ganz kluge formulierung dass das
was wir erlebt haben in den letzten
tagen und wochen wir haben sehr sehr
intensiv das ist schon gesagt worden und
sehr vertrauensvoll und vertraulich zu
manchem ärger
miteinander verhandelt so manches dazu
gelernt nicht nur über die beiden
partner über die fdp und über die über
bündnis 90 die grünen sondern auch über
uns selbst weil du uns ja auch mit
unseren eigenen positionen auseinander
setzen müssten um eben auch wege
zueinander zu finden und das ist schon
eine ganz besondere leistung wir haben
ein geschmiedet um gemeinsam fortschritt
zu wagen wir haben aber auch
verantwortung übernommen und werden das
auch weiterhin tun in der die korona
pandemie manche haben ist schon gesagt
das land und natürlich auch die menschen
stark belastet ihr vizekanzler die ampel
fraktionen ebenso wie die parteispitzen
waren und sind bereit alles nötige zu
tun um die gesundheit der bürgerinnen
und bürger zu schützen die bewältigung
dieser pandemie in angriff zu nehmen
weiterhin was wir uns für die zukunft
vorgenommen haben braucht viel mut wir
wollen den wandel in dem unser land in
dem unsere welt sich befindet aktiv
gestalten die dekarbonisierung ist
angesprochen worden die digitalisierung
ist angesprochen worden auch die
demografie natürlich eine wichtige
herausforderung aber eben auch die
wachsende anerkennung von vielfalt als
chance für den zusammenhalt in dieser
gesellschaft dieser wandel braucht nicht
nur eine mutige regierung wir alle
müssen mutig sein neues zu wagen und
dafür brauchen wir freiheit aber auch
sicherheit und zusammenhalt und daran
werden wir gemeinsam arbeiten
wir verstehen uns bei all dem als
partner in europa und in einer welt die
vieles nur gemeinsam kann das gilt für
die pandemie und andere krisen das gilt
aber auch für die wandel
ereignisse über die ich gesprochen habe
wir sind drei partner auch dass es schon
gesagt worden mit sehr unterschiedlichen
traditionen und auch mit
unterschiedlichen grundhaltung und alle
drei hatten wir einen weg zu gehen um
zusammenzufinden
wir begründen finde ich mit diesen neuen
bündnis auch eine neue form der
zusammenarbeit die neugierde und die
offenheit die wir aufgebracht haben für
die sichtweisen die argumente und die
herangehensweisen jeweils der anderen
das hat uns auch viele neue perspektiven
eröffnet ich finde das ist eine chance
auch für die politik politische kultur
in deutschland
das handelsblatt hat heute morgen haben
ein hesse zitiert und spricht von
gegnern die einander brauchen weil ohne
wind keine mühlen laufen das ist ein
schönes zitat und nicht als käuferin
möchte noch eins dazu führen fügen
nämlich dass aus dem stufen gedicht
allem anfang wohnt an jedem anfang wohnt
ein zauber inne das ist tatsächlich auch
etwas was ich heute empfinde das muss
ich ganz ehrlich so sagen wir sind
überzeugt dieser anfang ist uns gelungen
dieses bündnis steht für zukunft es ist
für die zukunft gemacht was wir uns
vorgenommen haben weist über die
legislatur hinaus und dafür legen wir
heute den grundstein für ein bündnis für
ein regierungsbündnis unter der führung
von bundeskanzler oder schulz
[Applaus]
dankeschön wir kommen zu ihren fragen
sie hatten in den letzten wochen
berechtigterweise viele fragen heute
gibt es die antworten ich bitte vorab um
verzeihung ich kenne sie nicht alle und
ich erkenne schon gar nicht alle mit
ihren masken deswegen wäre generell die
bitte einfach einmal namen und medium
sagen und ich versuche mich bemerkbar zu
machen genauso wie sie sich versuchen
bemerkbar zu machen um an diesen
mikrofone zu kommen die erste frage geht
an georg ismar vom tagesspiegel und
danach die kollegin zwei reihen dahinter
dann brauche ich mich jetzt ja nicht
noch mal extra vorstellen vielen dank
ich hätte eine frage an herrn scholz sie
haben eingangs sich zur corona lage
geäußert jetzt haben wir durch die heute
in kraft getretenen massnahmen die
sonder lage das wenn zum beispiel am 15
dezember in sachsen oder bayern lockdown
maßnahmen auslaufen dort bars clubs
gastronomie alles wieder öffnen muss ist
das wirklich verantwortbar und war es
nicht ein schwerer fehler dieses gesetz
jetzt so zu ändern hätte man es nicht
einfach weiterlaufen lassen sollen heute
treten sehr strenge regeln in kraft die
gesetzgeberisch möglich gemacht worden
sind viele davon gehen weit über das
hinaus was wir bisher in deutschland
hatten für nur erinnern an die
möglichkeiten die sich mit 3g am
arbeitsplatz verbinden 3g im
öffentlichen verkehr zwei änderung die
bisher in deutschland gar nicht möglich
gewesen sind trotzdem sind sie notwendig
weil sie den ernst der lage angemessen
sind das gilt auch für maßnahmen wie zb
im zusammenhang mit kontakt beschränkung
vielleicht für erforderlich gehalten
werden müssen den einzelnen bereichen
auch das ist mit vorbereitet dass wir
das jetzt machen können und jetzt geht
es um eine klare entschiedene politik
die dafür sorgt dass wir tagtäglich die
lage beobachten das ist der grund warum
wir vorschlagen dass es einen krisenstab
gibt er auch jetzt schon schnell
eingerichtet wird gerne auch bevor die
neue regierung ins amt gekommen ist
darum werden wir uns gemeinsam bemühen
dass das möglich ist so dass ein guter
übergang stattfinden kann und
gleichzeitig eine tägliche präsente
bekämpfung dieser corona
gesundheitskrise stattfinden kann es
gilt auch für die wissenschaftliche
begleitung die wir uns anders wünschen
als das bisher der fall ist wir wollen
nämlich präzise aus diskutierte
vorschläge haben und wir wollen ganz
konkret wissen wie entwickelt sich die
lage in den einzelnen bereichen werden
auch alle maßnahmen und alle neuen
möglichen maßnahmen umgesetzt also hier
ist klares geordnetes handeln
erforderlich dass man nichts vor sich
herschiebt sondern dass jeweils die
notwendigen entscheidungen getroffen
werden und das ist der feste wille der
kommenden regierung
spiekermann zdf hauptstadtstudio ich
würde ganz gerne bei einer personalie
noch mal nachhaken wohlmöglich die
wichtigste personalie wer
gesundheitsminister beziehungsweise
gesundheitsministerin wird
die sozialdemokratische partei wird ihre
entscheidung gut vorbereitet ich werde
entsprechende vorschläge machen das
werden wir tun
nachdem die beratung über die bildung
des koalitionsvertrages und die
unterstützung des koalitionsvertrages in
der spd abgeschlossen sind und wir
nutzen die zeit wir haben uns jetzt
darauf konzentriert die koalition
zustande zu bringen die nächsten tage
werde ich mich sehr intensiv an die
arbeit machen eine hervorragende
besetzung der sozialdemokratischen
ressource zustande zu bringen das
gleiche wird in den beiden anderen
parteien geschehen und der sie werden
dann eine gute lösung sehen
meine frage da vorne
herr scholz der tageszeitung telegraph
aus amsterdam
sie präsentieren heute ein
koalitionsvertrag wollen neue regierung
anführen das passiert in einem berliner
hafen über den
g20-gipfel hatten sie gesagt das wird
nur ein hafengeburtstag das haben wir
dann gesehen dass zehntausende bürger
dort alleine gelassen wurden aus dem ort
geplündert wurde stundenlang und sie
reden viel über respekt auch über
gerechtigkeit
und meine frage ist wo ist dieser
respekt wenn sie die unwahrheit gesagt
haben und bezüglich treffen mit der
warburg-bank also wie oft sie dort
zusammen waren und in dieser comex
affäre ist der start der deutsche staat
betrogen und meine frage ist warum haben
sie diese bank 47 millionen euro steuer
nach ausgeschenkt wobei deutsche richter
diese
personen gebrandmarkt haben aus
organisierte kriminelle dankeschön
vielen dank für ihre frage wir haben uns
den bei der bildung dieser regierung da
verständlich alles zu tun damit die
innere sicherheit in deutschland
gewährleistet ist die polizei bekommt
all die notwendige unterstützung die sie
braucht damit sie alles dafür tun kann
dass kriminalität in deutschland keine
chance hat wir haben dazu sehr präzise
vorschläge gemacht auch in
gesetzgeberischen rahmen und das wird
die arbeit dieser koalition bestimmen
eine frage pro person wir haben eine
frage von herrn roth links ard
und als nächstes die kollegin in der
ersten journalisten reihe
vielen dank für die alte herr scholz des
café gestern ein treffen im kanzleramt
mit der kanzlerin wo es offenbar um die
krone lage ging inwiefern dieses treffen
ihre meinung oder ihren blick auf die
korona lage noch mal verändert oder hat
sich dann nichts mehr
die kanzlerin ich haben uns in der
vergangenheit immer in einem sehr engen
austausch gefunden es ist sehr gut dass
das jetzt im übergang auch weiter
stattfindet und darum geht es jetzt ja
ganz konkret ich habe ja in sehr präzise
vorschläge gemacht über die wir in den
letzten tagen parallel zu den
koalitionsverhandlungen uns intensiv
unterhalten haben und die dazu beitragen
sollen dass wir diese lage die korona
lage in den griff bekommen und
selbstverständlich ist es das ansinnen
das ich habe und dazu sind auch gerade
diese gespräche wichtig dass die hier
vorgesehenen vorgehensweisen für die
zukunft schon jetzt schnell umgesetzt
werden denn wir brauchen tatkraft
jeder deutsche welle
change
deutschland steht zu seiner
verantwortung die wir haben im rahmen
der europäischen union wir sind das eine
große land mitten in europa das ganz
bestimmt den auftrag hat jeden tag dazu
beizutragen dass die europäische union
besser wird dass sie besser gelingt wir
sind nicht diejenigen die irgendwie am
rande stehen und kommentare verschicken
sondern wir sind diejenigen die mit dazu
beitragen wollen dass ein starkes
souveränes europa möglich wird und wir
wissen uns dort sehr eingebunden die
transatlantische partnerschaft
insbesondere die zusammenarbeit mit den
usa ist für die künftige regierung von
zentraler bedeutung und das wird etwas
sein auf das wär was
auch die nächsten jahre weiter unsere
politik bestimmen wird die welt wird
sich verändern sie wird multipolar das
heißt es gibt viele starke staaten und
mächte in der welt die einfluss nehmen
auf das künftige geschehen nicht nur die
usa und china wie manche diskutieren
auch viele andere nationen des
aufsteigenden asiens korea japan vietnam
indonesien malaysia indien zb starke
länder aus afrika und aus dem süden
amerikas werden ihre stimme deutlich
machen im hinblick auf das künftige
weltgeschehen und unsere aufgabe ist
dazu beizutragen dass es eine
multilaterale welt wird in der die
kooperation im vordergrund steht und wir
wissen dass wir alle für unsere
sicherheit gemeinsam verantwortung
tragen und das ist etwas was unsere
politik auch bestimmen wird und ein
aspekt ist immer wichtig was uns selber
ausmacht dass wir
demokratien sind dass wir für die
freiheit für das recht stehen das wird
natürlich auch eine rolle spielen denn
wir wissen uns mit einigen ländern zum
beispiel mit den vereinigten staaten
besonders verbunden weil uns diese werte
gemeinsam prägen
die nächste frage geht an herrn rinke
von mir aus gesehen links
und danach die kollegen gerade den
stolz ich hätte eine frage an sie zum
auch zum thema europa schließt im
prinzip da an wo genau ist die
europapolitische koordinierung
verantwortung übernehmen sie das mit ins
kanzleramt sie haben das ja jetzt im
finanzministerium gemacht und was genau
heißt die formulierung dass die grünen
einen auswahl oder nominierungsrecht für
die eu kommission haben wenn es keine
deutsche
eu-kommissionspräsidenten gibt heißt es
dass ihre amtszeit auf jeden fall
begrenzt ist
eins ist ganz klar wir werden gemeinsam
europapolitik machen da wird es
verschiedene orte geben an denen das
geschieht bei den finanzministern wenn
die
wirtschaftsminister zusammen kommen wenn
die außenminister zusammen kommen das
kennen sie und das wird natürlich von
der regierung als gemeinsame politik
entwickelt ich jedenfalls wünsche mir
dass uns da sind auch die
voraussetzungen zu schaffen denn wir
verfolgen da an gemeinsamen kursstufe
den koalitionsvertrag sehr genau
entnehmen können und im hinblick auf die
frage wie die personellen
weichenstellung für die zukunft
beschrieben sind ist es doch ganz klar
wir haben jetzt eine regierung gebildet
aber wir haben auch einige fälle für die
zukunft mit beschrieben und das ist so
freundlich wie möglich formuliert
patricia biene maja zdf hauptstadtstudio
ich habe die frage schon nach den
sondierungsgesprächen gestellt ich
wiederhole sie heute mit der hoffnung
auf eine antwort sie haben sich ja viel
vorgenommen sie haben gesagt es wird
richtig teuer sie müssen ganz viel
investieren gibt es inzwischen konkrete
zahlen wie viel investiert werden muss
und vor allen dingen wie genau sie das
finanzieren wollen
es ist wenn ich das vielleicht als
eingangs bemerkung machen darf aber da
sind wir viele hier mit dabei wir haben
uns vorgenommen dass das ein jahrzehnt
der investitionen wird das mit dieser
legislaturperiode und wir wollen ja auch
wieder gewählt werden mit der nächsten
legislaturperiode weitergeht da spielen
die investitionen eine zentrale rolle
die notwendig sind um den
menschengemachten klimawandel
aufzuhalten denn es ist ja auch zugleich
eine große industrielle modernisierung
die damit verbunden ist bei der
betrachtung der haushalts möglichkeiten
haben wir genau geschaut welche
entwicklungen für die zukunft eintreten
können wir haben das aufgabenportfolio
betrachtet und wir sind sicher dass wir
all die investitions
fragen die in dem koalitionsvertrag
aufgeworfen werden in den nächsten
jahren auch beantworten können nämlich
mit der finanzierung der investition
soweit es sich um öffentliche handelt
ein großer teil dessen was geschieht ist
ja ohnehin privatwirtschaftliche sind
investitionen die wir dann begleiten
durch forschungsunterstützung durch
anreize am anfang einer veränderung und
natürlich wenn es um die infrastruktur
geht wo eine große modernisierung
notwendig ist da sind sich aber alle
einig ich glaube das kann man für den
künftig für die finanzen sagen das kann
man für die wirtschaft sagen und ich
würde deshalb vorschlagen dass
vielleicht herr lindner und herr abel
zweiter bemerkungen zu machen
ich muss dem nichts hinzufügen ich auch
nicht also die antwort ist ja wir haben
uns das kleingedruckte bis hinaus wir
wollen wissen genau wie es bezahlen
dann machen wir die nächste frage an
henry pinsky und dann der kollege auf
der seite der macht
ins gesetz da einmal winken
er hat sich dank eine frage an christian
linder und zwar die drei außenpolitisch
relevanten ressourcen ist ja nicht bei
der fdp gelandet auch bei der position
des kommissars oder der kommissarin hat
die fdp jetzt kein zugriffsrecht beim
finanzministerium natürlich schon
deswegen wäre meine frage ist das der
weg wo die liberalen dann sozusagen
außenpolitischen einfluss ausüben wollen
oder haben sie sich ganz bewusst er auch
die innenpolitischen themen fokussiert
die zukünftige bundesregierung
beabsichtigt ja kollegial
zusammenzuarbeiten die wesentlichen
leitlinien unserer gemeinsamen arbeit
wollen wir miteinander besprechen das
umfasst die innenpolitik das umfasst
natürlich auch den bereich der
internationalen verantwortung dieses
landes speziell mit blick auf die fdp
ressorts haben sie zurecht dargestellt
dass das bundesministerium der finanzen
jahr in europa und der welt eng
eingebunden ist in abstimmungsprozesse
der ressortzuschnitt des
bundesministeriums der finanzen bleibt
bestehen und insofern gibt es darüber
auch eine möglichkeit das auf der
internationalen ebene die fdp weiter
auch mit präsent ist aber das will ich
ausdrücklich hinzufügen
ich glaube dafür alle zu sprechen
eine bundesministerin oder ein
bundesminister ist nicht der
bundesminister der fdp der spd oder der
grünen eine bundesministerin oder ein
bundesminister dient dem land
sebastian heinrich vom nach hinten
watson am kabel sie haben vorhin gemeint
sie seien jetzt auch im 15 grad fahrt
mit diesem koalitionsvertrag und haben
dass wenn ich sie richtig verstanden
habe aus dem steigenden preis der
emissionszertifikate abgeleitet
andererseits steht im koalitionsvertrag
die butterweiche formulierung
idealerweise zum kohleausstieg
idealerweise gelingt das schon bis 2030
wie schmerzhaft war das für sie habe und
frau berbalk diese formulierung zu
akzeptieren und an die anderen beiden
herrn scholz herr linder wie können sie
sozusagen den forderungen gerade junger
menschen damit im kern treten die ja
seit jahren für entschlosseneren
klimaschutz protestieren
ich hab das schon an anderen stellen
versucht zu erklären was ein sondierungs
kapiere ist ein dünnes papier ist ein
dokument des vertrauens nachweise ist
das gab es ja vorher gar nicht also im
politischen geschäft ein relativ neue
erfindung geboren aus einer zeit wo
parteien die klassischen politischen
lager überwinden müssen immer nicht
genau weiß was man sich da ein handeln
und umgekehrt genauso auch nicht genau
die partner dann zu wissen wer da
eigentlich so kommt davon abgesehen dass
vielleicht die zeit vorbei ist wenn man
überhaupt noch von politischen lagern
reden kann siehe dem projekt folgen was
wir hier auf leben also ist das ein
jungs papier in vieler hinsicht vage
gewesen und diese formulierung
idealerweise gab ein arbeitsauftrag für
die koalitionsverhandlungen und dieser
auftrag ist abgearbeitet worden so dass
jetzt im koalitionsvertrag im energie-
oder klimaschutz kapitel sehr präzise
maßnahmen beschrieben werden wie der
vorzeitige kohleausstieg bis 2030
gelingen kann ich habe schon gesagt wenn
der co2 preis des missionshauses nicht
unter 60 euro fällt dann lohnt es sich
nicht mehr die kohlekraftwerke zu
betreiben
das ist sichergestellt dass es so kommen
wird und insofern ist das was unseren
jungs habt ihr vielleicht noch vage war
neben anderen beispiel im
koalitionsvertrag jetzt sauber aufgelöst
und der nächste schritt ist dann eben
verlieren und gestaltung der
wirklichkeit dass es dazu kommt
die kollegin linken schulter sie war
weil er stolz und ich auch angesprochen
worden sind will ich gerne kurz eine
bemerkung machen
keine industrie nation wird größere
anstrengungen unternehmen beim schutz
des klimas
in der wirkung ist dieser
koalitionsvertrag das ambitionierteste
klimaschutzprogramm einer industrie
nation im grunde werden wir begrenzt
durch das was physikalisch und technisch
möglich ist
was politisch und ökonomisch erreichbar
ist ist in diesem vertrag geschrieben
und deshalb können wir gemeinsam vor die
jungen menschen treten die sie
angesprochen haben können sagen was
unternommen werden kann das werden wir
ins werk setzen und wir haben uns dabei
vorgenommen
diese große transformation zu erreichen
und zugleich
wohlstand beschäftigung und freiheit der
menschen zu erhalten wenn uns das
gelingt dann haben wir eine
verantwortung wahrgenommen die über uns
in deutschland hinaus reicht weil wenn
er mich dann ein pfad aufzeigen können
denen auch andere oft der welt
beschreiten können
wir nämlich viel hinzufügen aus meiner
sicht geht es um die größte industrielle
modernisierung deutschlands seit weit
über 100 jahren das ist ein ehrgeiziges
projekt das setzt den ausbau der
erneuerbaren energien in einem ganz
anderen tempel voraus als wir das bisher
gewohnt sind denn wir müssen die
bürgerinnen und bürger aber auch die
wirtschaft deutschlands mit der
notwendigen ressourcen nämlich strom aus
erneuerbaren energiequellen versorgen
das werden wir tun indem wir so
ambitioniert sind wie das hier gesagt
wurde und in dem koalitionsvertrag
detailliert beschrieben worden ist und
das wird auch die große aufgabe sein
denn wir müssen es hinbekommen dass wir
2045 klimaneutral wirtschaften aus
meiner sicht ist das gut für unser land
und gleicht sich gut für die welt denn
wenn wir die technologien und die
fähigkeiten entwickeln die erforderlich
sind damit man wirtschaftlich
wettbewerbsfähig global wettbewerbsfähig
industrielle produktion betreiben kann
die gleichzeitig für das klima gut ist
dann ist das ein vorbild das andere
nachmachen können und das nicht dient
dann endgültig auch den
anforderungen die der klimawandel an uns
stellt
jetzt wie angekündigt die kollegen mit
einer letzten frage vielen dank marine
komparative paris frau berg noch mal
eine frage zur außenpolitischen
koordinierung wir haben im laufe des
sommers gesehen irgendwelche fatalen
folgen ein mangel in der
außenpolitischen koordinierung haben
kann mit blick auf die ortskräfte in
afghanistan ich glaube die debatte
gebaren nationalen sicherheitsrat dem
haben sie sich nicht angeschlossen
sprechen im koalitionsvertrag aber von
koordinierung was ist ihre antwort
darauf wird mehr im kanzleramt geben
wird im auswärtigen amt mehr impulse für
eine in einer regierungs abstimmungen
ausgegeben
ich darf ich das so beantworten wir es
hier schon 23 mal von jedem und jeder
von uns gesagt worden dass es gibt eine
bundesregierung und wir werden gemeinsam
handeln das ist in allen feldern der
politik der fall auch im bereich der
außenpolitik
ja schon jetzt auch ein
nationalen sicherheitsrat und wir haben
in diesem koalitionsvertrag das haben
wir für die klimapolitik deutlich
gemacht aber auch für die europa politik
sehr sehr deutlich gemacht die ja nicht
aus einem ressort heraus alleine betreut
wird sondern querschnitts mäßig in allen
bereichen der nächsten bundesregierung
die das bisher auch schon der fall ist
verankert ist und so wird die
zusammenarbeit sowohl in europa politik
als auch in der gemeinsamen außen aber
eben auch wie sie angesprochen haben in
der sicherheitspolitik gemeinsam in
dieser koalition erfolgen
danke schön danke für ihre fragen es tut
mir leid dass sie nicht alle stellen
konnten wir haben die nächsten tage und
wochen sicherlich noch die gelegenheit
ihre fragen zu stellen und auch
antworten zu bekommen die
pressekonferenz ist jetzt beendet kommen
sie gut nach hause und büros
da wird es jetzt auch das eine und
andere lange gesicht geben dass die
pressekonferenz zu diesem zeitpunkt
schon zu ende ist weil es sind ja auch
noch ziemlich viele fragen offen
geblieben zu diesem koalitionsvertrag
relativ wenig fragen konnten gestellt
werden zu einigen details es war doch
mehr jetzt im allgemeinen bereich und
ich glaube das war auf der anderen seite
auch sinn und zweck dieser
pressekonferenz hier dass man erst mal
einen groben überblick gibt über das was
man vorhat und dass man vor allem erst
mal zeigt dass man auch zusammen
gekommen ist in diesem rund 177 seiten
starken papier und auch war es ein
kleiner ausblick auf die art und weise
wie diese koalition in zukunft
zusammenarbeiten will ob ihr das dann
gelingt es ist ja dann immer eine andere
frage aber durchaus bemerkenswert fand
ich die eingangs bemerkungen die ist
hier von den jeweiligen protagonisten
gegeben hat robert habeck hat den
koalitionsvertrag ein dokument des mutes
und der zuversicht genannt und war fast
ein wenig emotional dabei
eine demut angesichts der aufgabe hat
christian lindner empfunden und dann
später auch nochmals die kollegiale
regierung betont dass es nicht darum
gehe und einzelne interessen einzelner
parteien durchzusetzen sondern als
gemeinsame regierung aufzutreten eine
koalition auf augenhöhe hat olaf scholz
das genannt und saskia esken ein bündnis
für die zukunft sehr dass alles
funktioniert werden wir in den kommenden
wochen und monaten dann sehen der
auftakt ist erst mal gemacht jetzt geht
es weiter ins verfahren das bedarf der
zustimmung aller drei parteien natürlich
zu diesem koalitionsvertrag
und ist man darf natürlich noch der
einen und anderen personalliste die spd
wird ihre ministerinnen und minister für
diese ampel koalition nicht vor dem
vierten dezember vorstellen dann ist ein
kleiner parteitag im willy brandt haus
bei dem über das sowohl das den
koalitionsvertrag als daneben auch über
das personaltableau abgestimmt werden
wird von der fdp hören wir dass die
namen möglicherweise sogar schon heute
kommen und bestätigt werden es gab ja
diesen wirklich ulkigen kleinen
versprecher von olaf scholz der bei
einer frage das wort an den zukunft und
dann hat er gestoppt und hat gesagt das
sei eine frage der finanzen und hat das
wort dann an christian lindner gegeben
und die grünen schließlich so ist zu
hören werden ihr personal möglicherweise
morgen vorstellen also heute auch noch
nicht also ist also noch einiges in
bewegung insgesamt rund um diese
zukünftige regierung werden auch der
fahrplan jetzt offensichtlich aber
eingehalten werden kann und das würde
bedeuten in der nikolaus woche nicht nur
unterzeichnung des koalitionsvertrags da
wird man sehen wie groß das ausfallen
kann wie üblich in früheren jahren gab
es das auch schon mal im paul-löbe-haus
des bundestages mit vielen vielen gästen
das ist im moment unwahrscheinlich und
das bringt mich zu einem anderen
wichtigen punkt und abschließenden das
mal alle hier nämlich bei dieser
pressekonferenz das thema corona betont
haben inklusive einer reihe von
informationen die olaf scholz gleich zu
beginn gegeben hat etwa krisenstab von
bund und ländern kanzleramt angesiedelt
und eine expertenkommission die
regelmäßig tagen soll der franko ja er
hat natürlich das ist das technische und
das prozedere dass das eine das andere
ist das inhaltliche und als
hauptstadtkorrespondent schaust du ja
auch eben darauf deshalb trendwenden und
kontinuität zufrieden mit dem was da
geliefert wurde
das ist ja nicht an mir das zu
beurteilen und ich glaube es ist auf
jeden fall auch zu früh das jetzt zu
beurteilen welche ich schon gesagt habe
wir haben noch nicht viele gelegenheiten
gehabt uns mit diesem koalitionsvertrag
auseinanderzusetzen es gibt einzelne
mosaiksteinchen die im laufe des
nachmittags von den pressekonferenzen
genannt worden sind also ein paar sachen
die ja ohnehin klar waren dass sie
kommen müssten und die innerhalb die
pardon innerhalb dieser konstellation
also der mindestlohn von zwölf euro die
kindergrundsicherung auf der einen seite
themen wie klimaschutz und die wege
dorthin insbesondere auch ein relativ
strenges regiment wie die grünen dass in
diesem zusammenhang fordern auf der
anderen seite finanzpolitische aspekte
wie sie die fdp immer eingefordert hat
auch da haben wir den einen und anderen
punkt ja im laufe des nachmittags
gesehen aber das muss man jetzt zusammen
fügen müssen und die bewertung dessen
was er tatsächlich zusammengetragen
worden ist die wird sicherlich erst in
den kommenden wochen und monaten möglich
sein nämlich dann wenn es ans
eingemachte geht wenn es ans regieren
geht und wenn dann die und dann die
entscheidende frage kommt ist das was
diese drei parteien sich vorgenommen
haben tatsächlich auch so umzusetzen
funktioniert das mit dem kollegialen
umgang funktioniert es damit sich
gegenseitig punkte zu gönnen und
funktioniert das vor allem ein
übergreifendes
innovativ wie es neuerdings immer so
schön heißt zu entwickeln also nicht nur
die einzelnen parteiprogramme und
wahlprogramme umzusetzen sondern
gemeinsam wie es auch neuerdings immer
so schön heißt die transformation von
wirtschaft gesellschaft aber auch der
demokratie insgesamt voran zu treiben
und den gesellschaftlichen zusammenhalt
zu fördern etc alles was dazu gehört da
wird diese ampel koalition wie es auch
für alle vorherigen gegolten hat
sicherlich nicht an diesem
koalitionsvertrag gemessen werden
sondern an dem was im alltag ein problem
auftritt und dann wie sie diese probleme
lösen dass es nicht einfach ist haben
sie nicht nur in den
koalitionsverhandlungen gemerkt sie
haben es ja auch eingestanden dass das
ganze nicht immer einfach gewesen ist
aber sie merken es in den vergangenen
tagen auch daran dass schwierige pro
krisen wie wir sie im moment mit krone
haben gar nicht so einfach zu händeln
sind und auch da mit den
unterschiedlichen parteiprogramm im
hintergrund wird in dieser ampel
koalition beispielsweise am thürmer
thema corona beweisen müssen dass sie so
funktioniert wie sieht es heute hier
versprochen hat ja und wir freuen uns
dort sind weiterhin auch auf analysen
und bewertungen unserer hauptstadt
korrespondenten für den moment sage ich
danke schön wir reden daher weiter
erhard scherfer erst einmal danke nach
berlin
ihr habt jetzt wechseln wir das bild und
das bücherregal ist geblieben oder
professor der politikwissenschaft lehrt
gewechselt professor meinel richter ich
grüße sie ganz herzlich
traurig jetzt aber die bewertung dessen
zu was da inhaltlich im vertrag steht ja
also ich habe noch keine gelegenheit
gehabt den vertrag in händen zu halten
und jetzt ausführlich zu studieren aber
aus den stellungnahmen konnte man schon
entnehmen dass im grunde erst mal alle
themen angesprochen worden sind das wäre
ja auch eine strategie gewesen dass
heikle und das umstrittene auszusparen
das scheint nicht der fall gewesen zu
sein was man hört ist 147 seiten lang
oder etwa in dieser 100 777 sogar also
das heißt er ist relativ lang geraten
frühere
koalitionsverträge und vereinbarung
waren deutlich kürzer unter 30 und 2005
1 klar bist du kann über 90 seiten also
es ist wieder mal ein sehr langes
dokument geworden und was ich
bemerkenswert finde ist auch die
überschrift das ist schon mal sehr gut
gelungen also andererseits das stichwort
fortschritt was ja sicher ein bisschen
auch gegen die konservativen bandit
gegen die cdu gerichtet ist und dann
eben diese drei stichworte die
einerseits den einzelnen
koalitionspartner zuzuordnen sind also
freiheit der fdp gerechtigkeit der spd
nachhaltigkeit den grünen aber die
eigentlich auch wenn man es genau nimmt
doch irgendwie auch ein ja dieses
bündnis charakterisieren die
zusammengehörigkeit jeder dieser
koalitionspartner kann sich unter diesen
stichworten irgendwie wieder finden das
finde ich erst mal ein zeichen des
gelungenen beieinander science und das
hand die drei oder vier oder sieben
partner wie auch immer man zieht das
haben die ja jetzt erst mal sehr sehr
klar und deutlich formuliert und das
hinter dem bundeskanzler in zukünftigen
ausdrücklich als person lobt das war das
schon sehr bemerkenswert also da
herrscht einigkeit und entschlossenheit
gemeinsam aufzutreten und in dieser
überschrift mehr fortschritt wagen ist
das dritte wort wagen
sie dürfen ja ja ja ja also ich meine
fortschritt ist natürlich ein heikler
begriff denn wir sehen ja dass der
bisherige fortschritt viele missstände
und auch wenn man so will rückschritte
mit sich gebracht hat und wir stehen vor
großen herausforderungen
das wurde ja auch betont also so etwas
wie nicolo corona pandemie weltweit das
kannten ihr ereignis dann natürlich das
große thema umwelt und klima
schädigungen und da ist man natürlich
erstmal etwas skeptisch und konnte ins
grübeln ob fortschritt der richtige
begriff sei diese vorhaben die vor uns
stehen wirklich gut zu charakterisieren
also mit anderen worten man muss
eigentlich von bestimmten vorstellungen
des fortschritts abschied nehmen und
neue vorstellen vorstellungen und und
andere und reflektierte und durchdachte
entwickeln das haben die ja offenbar vor
also insofern ist das durchaus spannend
wie sich dieser fortschritt dann auch in
den einzelnen formulierungen des
koalitionsvertrags realisiert und
natürlich vor allen dingen wie es
ausgehen wird in den blick dann auf die
vier jahre die der regierungsarbeit die
vor denen stehen das muss man klar aber
dann hat ja auch gehört diese zwei worte
effektiver und vor allen dingen auch
schneller willmann werden es ist ein
schönes vorhaben oder ja das ist
natürlich wenn man so wie ein bisschen
trivial wald das wollen natürlich
eigentlich alle her dass man sagt also
wir packen es jetzt an und wir machen es
besser und schneller als alle anderen
ist man vieles das haben wir ja gesehen
wird davon abhängen welche akuten krisen
karte im moment vorhanden sind und da
gibt es ja einige und das fand sich auch
sehr bemerkenswert dass eben der noch
nicht gekürte aber voraus sich diese
bundeskanzler scholz zunächst einmal mit
einem corona statement begann also das
heißt man sieht dass man eben in der
krisen und zwar eine sehr akuten krisen
lage ist einen bedrohlichen krisenlage
und man will damit auch glaube ich ein
bisschen reagieren auf die kritik die es
in den letzten tagen gab diese neue
koalitionsverhandlung die kümmern sich
gar nicht um die akute krise und neben
zum corona problem gar anstellung also
das hat man glaube ich damit erst einmal
jetzt vom tisch gewischt und dann hat
eben gezeigt also man will da irgendwie
auch natürlich als krisenmanager in
erscheinung treten und das wird die
anfangs politik der nächsten
bundesregierung sicherlich ganz massiv
bestimmen ja wir müssen mal ganz kurz
über eine episode die sich dann jetzt in
dieser frage runde ereignete reden als
der zukünftige kanzlerin angesprochen
wurde auf so diverse
finanzskandal geschichten und auch g20
gipfel das hat er dann einfach liegen
gelassen sozusagen weggeschmolzen holt
ihnen das noch mal irgendwann wieder ein
oder ist das weg naja es laufen ja da
nach wie vor ermittlungen und insofern
würde ich sagen das ist noch nicht vom
tisch aber das war seine strategie auch
schon in der vergangenheit dass er an
dieser stelle immer ganz wortkarg
geworden ist und sich so ein bisschen
selbst heraus genommen hat aus diesem
problem nun aus den anschuldigungen die
kursieren und geklärt ist es in der tat
ja doch nicht also es kann schon auch
mal sein dass da irgendetwas
deutlich wird und öffentlich wird was
eben ihm auch schaden kann aber ich
glaube das würde ich jetzt einer
kanzlerwahl scholz nicht massiv im wege
stehen das haben sie sehr schön
formulierte entwicklung hat es immer
noch mal ganz kurz in die in die punkte
um die es geht und wenn man so schaut
was man vorhat also focus rente kinder
digitalisierung auch pflege
wohnen das ist ja schon ein sehr
deutlicher ausmaß dessen was man
eigentlich will also es passiert dann
tatsächlich was in diesem land
ja wobei man sagen muss ich meinen auch
die die bisherige
koalitionsregierung die ihr noch
geschäftsführend im amt ist hatte sich
in ihrem koalitionsvertrag einige große
vorhaben vorgenommen das ist ja auch
üblich und ich bezweifle und das ist
natürlich die erfahrung des beobachters
dass all diese vorhaben dann auch
letztendlich nach vier jahren umgesetzt
werden können also das sind immer
absichtserklärungen das darf man nicht
vergessen und vor dem hintergrund ist es
aber deutlich geworden dass es
tatsächlich so ein paar dinge gibt die
im schuh drücken das ist natürlich nach
wie vor dieses große globale thema
umwelt und klimaschutz und dann aber
tatsächlich auch natürlich vor dem
hintergrund der krone pandemie finanzen
na also die steuerfrage steuerpolitik
schuldenbremse was dann auch sofort auch
in die außenpolitik hineinführt wie geht
man auf europäischer ebene damit um wo
deutschland ein wichtiger partner ist
und dann die sozialen probleme die
wurden ja angesprochen tatsächlich die
rentenversorgung vor dem hintergrund
einer sogenannten überalterung das heißt
an der zunehmende zahl an seniorinnen
und senioren die versorgt werden müssen
von der arbeitenden generationen also da
ist der generationenvertrag gefordert
und sowas wie mieten also die sozialen
probleme für diejenigen zu lindern die
eben in der sozial schwachen
wirtschaftlich schwachen position sind
also gehörige aufgaben catalunya so
haben jetzt das roundup schon gebracht
wunderbar ich sage an dieser stelle erst
mal danke schön bleiben sie noch bitte
bei uns und vor dem bücherregal
wir schauen mal auf das was der
zukünftige kanzler olaf scholz heute
gesagt hat
die ampel steht
spd grüne und fdp haben sich in den
verhandlungen auf einen gemeinsamen
koalitionsvertrag verständigt und damit
auf ein neues regierungsbündnis
diesen vertrag legen wir nun unseren
parteien zur abstimmung vor und wir
werben intensiv dafür dass alle drei
parteien diesen vertrag in den nächsten
zehn tagen zustimmen werden
unser ziel ist das erste bündnis von rot
grün und gelb auf bundesebene zu führen
eine koalition auf augenhöhe mit drei
partnern die ihre stärken einbringen zum
wohle unseres landes
und der glaube an den fortschritt und
daran dass politik etwas gutes bewirken
kann uns eint der wille das land besser
zu machen es voran zu bringen und es
beisammen zu halten
es geht uns nicht um eine politik des
kleinsten gemeinsamen nenners sondern um
eine politik der großen wirkung
wir wollen uns etwas zutrauen beim
klimaschutz ein umbau unserer industrie
bei der modernisierung des landes bei
der stärkung des gesellschaftlichen
zusammenhalts
wir wollen mehr fortschritt tragen
mit ehrgeiz und beharrlichkeit werden
wir unser land zum vorreiter beim
klimaschutz machen mit dem konsequenten
und zügigen ausbau der erneuerbaren
energien mit einer beschleunigung des
planungsrechts die industrie
unterstützen wir beim umstieg auf
klimaneutrale produktion
spitzentechnologie made in germany wird
es auch in zukunft geben
im wahlkampf habe ich viel über respekt
gesprochen ein respekt der eine menge
mit anerkennung zu tun hat aber dort
nicht verraten ich bin froh dass wir
miteinander vereinbart haben den
mindestlohn in einem schritt auf 12 euro
zu erhöhen wie ich es angekündigt habe
das bedeutet eine gehaltserhöhung für
zehn millionen bürgerinnen und bürger
wir führen die kindergrundsicherung ein
die armut verhindern und bessere chancen
für kinder und jugendliche schaffen wird
zugleich halten wir die rente wie
versprochen stabil und entwickeln sie
fort
und wir haben miteinander vereinbart im
kampf gegen hohe mieten den wohnungsbau
voran zu treiben
400.000 neue wohnungen pro jahr davon
100.000 öffentlich gefördert werden wir
bauen
die modernisierung unseres landes gibt
es nicht zum nulltarif
wir werden massiv investieren um
deutschland in der weltspitze zu halten
diese investitionen haben wir
miteinander vereinbart und dabei werden
wir die schuldenbremse einhalten dem
grundgesetz garantiert ist
ein souveränes europa ist der schlüssel
und für unsere außenpolitik als
wirtschaftlich starkes und
bevölkerungsreichen land im herzen
europas ist es unsere aufgabe diese
souveräne europa zu ermöglichen zu
fördern und voranzubringen
die freundschaft zu frankreich
die partnerschaft mit den vereinigten
staaten und der einsatz für frieden und
wohlstand in der welt sind die säulen
auf denen unsere außenpolitik fußt
und nun lassen sie mich noch ein paar
sätze sagen zu den verhandlungen der
vergangenen wochen die sie gelegentlich
von ferne verfolgen konnten wofür ich
mich nicht entschuldigen möchte
in diesen tagen und wochen haben wir eng
intensiv und mitunter leidenschaftlich
vor allem aber vertrauensvoll
miteinander verhandelt alle drei
parteien seien es die grünen angeführt
von annalena baerbock und robert habeck
die liberalen von christian lindner oder
die spd mit saskia esken und norbert
walter borjans alle haben diese
gespräche mit großem engagement geführt
konstruktiv und immer lösungsorientiert
angetrieben vom willen das land gut zu
regieren und es voran zu bringen
das hat mir gut gefallen und in mir das
gefühl verstärkt dass hier tatsächlich
etwas zusammengewachsen wachsen ist in
der koalition
die erste verkehrsampel ist im jahre
1924 in berlin errichtet worden am
potsdamer platz
damals zunächst noch eine ungewöhnliche
technik kann das funktionieren
haben die leute skeptisch gefragt heute
ist die ampel nicht mehr wegzudenken
wenn es darum geht die dinge klar zu
regeln und für die richtige orientierung
zu sorgen und dafür dass alle zügig und
sicher vorankommen
mein anspruch als bundeskanzler ist es
dass dieses ampelbündnis eine ähnlich
wegweisende rolle für deutschland
spielen wird schön danke
wir weisen schon mal darauf hin dass wir
auf politische reaktionen warten
angekündigt ist für 16.30 also für jetzt
ein beitrag der afd nach der verkündung
da sehen wir das bild nach der
verkündung des koalitionsvertrages
vielleicht hatte man da auch schon ein
bisschen zeit zu lesen professor richter
es gibt ja auch länder die hatten nur
eine ampel bisher und die wurde sogar
wieder abgeschafft also das bild ist ein
witziges bild aber eine ampel ist
natürlich schon auf bundesebene jetzt
mal ganz was neues ein projekt außerdem
mit drei parteien
wie dicht sind die tatsächlich
beieinander was ist so ihre einschätzung
ja also ich möchte das was sie gesagt
haben zunächst einmal noch
unterstreichen das ist geradezu
historische das hatten wir in
deutschland noch nie und das ist
natürlich auch ein produkt der des
mehrparteiensystems wir hatten ja über
lange jahrzehnte drei parteien und dann
wurden es immer mehr und ihr zins sieben
oder acht je nachdem wie man zählt und
jetzt eben dieses dreierbündnis was
wirklich ein experiment ist was neues
ist aber was sowie die sich die kohle
die künftigen koalitionäre sich
ausgedrückt haben irgendwie auch
erfolgversprechend wirkt und ich glaube
im vorfeld war ja eigentlich erst mal
die befürchtung geäußert worden die sind
ganz weit auseinander also insbesondere
die fdp gegenüber der spd aber auch
gegenüber den grünen und herr lindner
hat das ja heute mehrfach betont dass er
eben tatsächlich das auch so sieht wie
der künftige bundeskanzler also eine
gemeinsamkeit das sind nicht mehr nur
drei partner die irgendwie zusammen
wirken wollen sondern die was einiges
zum ausdruck bringen wollen die wirklich
was gemeinsam es zum ausdruck bringen
wollen also dieser dieser
entschlossenheit wird sicherlich über
manches vielleicht auch hinweghelfen was
dann unweigerlich kommt nämlich dass es
nicht drei partner dann auch mal
untereinander uneins sind zerstreiten
gar oder irgendwie miteinander geraten
also ich bin natürlich gespannt wie das
dann weitergeht und wie das tatsächlich
in der realität aussieht aber die
entschlossenheit dann einhelliges ein
mutiges verhalten zum ausdruck zu
bringen die fans schon bemerkenswert da
hatte man ja würde es bei der fdp auch
schon mal andere erlebnisse die jetzt
natürlich dann umso erfreulicher sind
dass man sich da wirklich versammelt und
zwar in der mitte also das hat ja nun
auch christian lind noch einmal sehr
deutlich gesagt wir sind eine mitte
regierung in der mitte ist aber
eigentlich noch eine andere partei
verortet oder sieht sich zumindest
verortet das ist die union
ja die sind jetzt zum zuschauen verdammt
aber auch zum zum abwarten ob diese
ampel erfolgreich ist und was dann was
dann mit der union ja
das ist natürlich eine frage die also
einerseits natürlich von dem erfolg
dieser ampel abhängig ist aber zunächst
einmal glaube ich von innerparteilichen
prozessen in der cdu und da ist ja auch
die frage wie weit ist man in der mitte
also das ist schon die frage die sich an
diese partei selbst auch sehr
fundamental stellt ja was ist
konservatismus in unseren heutigen
zeiten was ist das was man frau merkel
immer vorgehalten hat die
sozialdemokratisierung der cdu also dies
ist noch mehr in die mitte rücken was
ist der anspruch einer volkspartei die
eben ja eigentlich dadurch definiert ist
dass sie alle möglichen strömungen und
bedürfnisse und wünsche unter ihren gut
vereint diese diskussion steht der cdu
noch bevor die ist längst noch nicht
gelöst die wird natürlich erst mal davon
abhängen wer wirklich
parteivorsitzender wird professorin
richter für den moment sagte ich danke
schön wir gehen mal noch mal nach berlin
in den westhafen dort wo wir grad die
vorstellung des koalitionsvertrages
erlebt haben danke für den moment dort
ist jetzt nämlich mein kollege erhard
scherfer und er hat hat eine
ministerpräsidentin leibhaftig man höher
schwer sich bei sich
so ist das wir sind dem event &
convention center westhafen hier in
berlin und das ganze findet unter zweig
plus regeln statt deswegen können wir
auch mal den abstand minimal verkürzen
irgendwie aber ich glaube wir haben
einen guten meter zwischen uns frau
schließlich schön dass das klappt frau
ministerpräsidentin wir haben der
pressekonferenz hier ausführlich
zugehört was ist aus ihrer sicht das
besondere an dieser neuen ampel
koalition das besondere an dieser neuen
koalition ist dass das thema
wirtschaftliche stärke soziale
gerechtigkeit und ökologische
verantwortung zusammen gebunden wird das
darf nicht gegeneinander stehen wir
müssen wirtschaft soziales und umwelt
zusammen bekommen dafür stehen alle drei
partner und ich selber habe in den
koalitionsverhandlungen erlebt dass alle
um den besten weg streiten aber dass man
auch gut miteinander umgeht und ich
glaube dass die menschen ein großes
vertrauen in diese ampel koalition legen
können und ganz besonders in den
zukünftigen kanzler scholz das ist
mehrfach betont worden auch dass man
anders zusammenarbeiten will als das
denn aus früheren koalition so kennt
also das man auch kollegial auftreten
will jetzt auch auf der basis der
gespräche die bislang geführt worden
sind fügen wie groß ist die chance dass
das natürlich auch so klappt denn
irgendwann kommt ja der alltag ich bin
da sehr zuversichtlich und war selber in
den koalitionsverhandlungen an denen ich
teilgenommen habe ganz positiv
überrascht das ist gar nicht so ein
gegeneinander ist was sich oft zwischen
spd und cdu in der großen koalition
erlebt habe da ging es oft mehr
gegeneinander als anstatt ein
miteinander und hier obwohl wir sehr
unterschiedliche positionen haben zu
bestimmten fragen hat man dem anderen
zugehört und hat man nach gemeinsamen
lösung gesucht und da bin ich nenne die
spd kantig ich wusste dass wir
inhaltlich und verhandlungstag sind aber
ich bin auch sehr positiv von fdp und
grünen überrascht über diese
konstruktive art über den fairen umgang
lassen so ein bisschen teilhaben noch an
diesen gesprächen von denen wir ja im
grunde nichts mitbekommen haben
teilweise ja noch nicht mal wussten wo
sie dann auch gerade stattfinden es gab
ja zwischendrin durchaus auch
anmerkungen aus reihen der grünen die
sagen es ist alles sehr sehr schwierig
und wir wir tun uns auch ein bisschen
schwer unsere positionen hier
durchzusetzen lassen so ein bisschen
teilhaben wie das ganze abgelaufen ist
und wie sie dann auch zusammen wieder
auf die spur gekommen sind oder in die
spur besser gesagt in dem erst mal jeder
dem anderen zugehört hat was ist ein
punkt und die grünen machen natürlich
total druck bei klima und das auch
richtig und wichtig aber die spd zum
beispiel sagt wenn wir diese wandlungen
in der gesellschaft in allen
lebensbereichen machen zu mehr
klimaneutralität dann müssen wir es auch
sozial abfedern weil wir dürfen die
bürger nicht dabei verlieren und dass
vielleicht ein schönes beispiel wie man
gut zusammen kommt und dass eben umwelt
und soziales zusammenpassen muss ich
ganz irgendwann mal auf der kippe ich
hatte zu keinem zeitpunkt den eindruck
dass es wirklich auf der kippe stand
sondern es gab punkte die waren ganz
ganz wichtig so wie zum beispiel für uns
als spd die rentengarantie der
mindestlohn und auch der kampf gegen
kinderarmut und natürlich hat jeder so
seine punkte aber das gute ist wir haben
dann nicht die punkte gegeneinander
getauscht wird es so manchmal der
politik üblich ist sondern nach
gemeinsamen lösungen gesucht und es
stand eigentlich nie auf der kippe aber
es wurde auch hart gerungen und das ist
auch richtig so weil die bürgerinnen und
bürger haben es verdient dass man dem
besten weg fürs land findet wo was am
schwersten aus ihrer sicht zusammen zu
kommen
schweers glaube ich
die die fina ist schwer sind die
finanziellen rahmenbedingungen
die bundesregierung hat finanzielle
rahmenbedingungen wie wir auch in den
ländern dass wir durch die krone
pandemie jetzt viel geld natürlich in
die abfederung der pandemie stecken
mussten und man sich dann entscheiden
muss was ist jetzt für uns priorität was
wollen wir als erstes an investitionen
auf den weg bringen und das ist gar
nicht dass da die parteien auseinander
sind sondern dass man die verantwortung
trägt schauen sie eine opposition da
kann man alles fordern und sagen aber
eine regierung muss das was man
vorschlägt nachher auch funktionieren
wie schwer wird das corona dieser
regierung machen dieser neuen wir haben
sie in den vergangenen tagen schon
beobachtet dass entscheidung auch ein
bisschen korrigiert werden mussten schon
wieder und die lage wird ja nicht besser
im moment die wichtigste aufgabe der
neuen bundesregierung ist unser land gut
und sicher aus der pandemie zu führen
und das verdammt schwer das geht nur
gemeinsam auch parteiübergreifend und
ich bin sehr dankbar dass die ampel
koalition sich gleich rat geholt hat
auch bei den ländern wie können wir
damit umgehen und ich wünsche mir dass
die neue bundesregierung eben nicht
abwartet und dann immer alarmstimmung
macht sondern früh sich mit uns ländern
zusammensetzt und sagt mit den
wissenschaftlern wie es die lage was
müssen wir zusammen tun und da ist die
einrichtung eines ständigen krisenstabes
von bund und ländern aber auch die
einrichtung einer ständigen
expertenkommission die tag aktuell berät
genau das richtige instrument würde
gerne nochmal kurz balkone auf bleiben
müssen die maßnahmen die bislang
beschlossenen sind von den zukünftigen
koalitionäre noch sind sicher nicht im
amt müssen diese maßnahmen noch einmal
verschärft werden oder reicht das was im
moment da ist was in letzter zeit häufig
instrumentenkasten genannt wurde reicht
ihnen das aus die neue koalition hat ja
schärfere instrumente auf den weg
gebracht zum beispiel 3g am arbeitsplatz
das hat mir bisher nicht das ist ganz
ganz wichtig in der arbeitswelt finden
viele ansteckungen stark dass man da ein
weder geimpft genesen oder auch getestet
ist und der zweite punkt olaf scholz hat
hier heute gesagt dass die ampel
koalition von den wissenschaftlern jetzt
sich beraten lässt funktionieren die
maßnahmen man braucht auch ein paar tage
sie müssen jetzt sehr wirken wir haben
sie jetzt erst in kraft gesetzt und sich
dann mit uns zusammen setzt und guckt ob
wir noch nachschärfen muss abschließend
vor schwesig ihrem corona erwähnt
klimaschutz ist ein großes thema
digitalisierung ist ein großes thema
gesellschaftlicher zusammenhalt ist und
vielleicht ein noch größeres thema die
aufgaben dieser koalition sind riesig
wenn man das mal genauer sich anguckt wo
sind die risiken
die risiken sind darin dass wir es nicht
schaffen und das darf auf gar keinen
fall passieren sondern dass wir wirklich
diese großen krisen corona krise
klimakrise
hinbekommen aber gleichzeitig dabei das
land zusammenzuhalten und da bin ich
ganz sicher dass das olaf scholz
gelingen wird als kanzler denn er ist
jemand der nicht spaltet sondern dinge
zusammenführt dann bringt er die
erfahrung mit und hat mich in den
verhandlungen sehr beeindruckt auch so
die verhandlungen zu führen er hat es
immer zusammengedacht und nicht
auseinander und wichtig ist für uns egal
wie schwer die krisen im land sind das
land muss zusammenbleiben frau
ministerpräsidentin schwierig vielen
dank dass sie zu uns gekommen sind hier
nach dieser pressekonferenz zum ampel
koalitionsvertrag in dem in den nächsten
tagen noch ein bisschen tiefer
eintauchen müssen um dann auch nochmal
details zu besprechen 1 200 zurück zu
stephan kulle dankeschön frau
ministerpräsidentin dankeschön die war
er hat vielen dank dafür ja wir wollen
mal auf die politischen reaktionen
schauen wie gerade schon angekündigt von
der afg gibt es eine stimme dazu timo
grub anadarko parteichef
herzlich willkommen zu unserem presse
statement nach den koalitions
vertragsverhandlungen den wir jetzt in
aller eile schnell durchflogen haben und
hier vielleicht unser erstes statement
dazu abgeben möchten
als auf die bundestagsfraktion mit
diesen koalitionsvertrag kommen in der
tat wirklich schwere zeiten auf
deutschland und seine bürger zu es
drohen auf allen ebenen mehr staatliche
eingriffe mehr gängelung mehr
finanzielle belastung und damit weniger
freiheit diese ampel ist keine koalition
der mitte sie ist ein linkes projekt das
eine deutliche links grüner handschrift
trägt und in der die fdp nur als
anhängsel dean und ich musste ein
bisschen schmunzeln also ich gerade
christian linder in seinem presse
statement hören sagte dass das eine
regierung der mitte sei also das ist
wirklich die erste
linklink bundesregierung mit fdp
beteiligung und die ampel koalition wird
den bürger
auch teuer zu stehen kommen wie sich
schon auch bei der klimapolitik zeigen
wird wirtschaft und wohlstand werden in
der ampel der grünen klima ideologie
vollkommen untergeordnet dafür steht das
superministerium für klima und
wirtschaft das noch dazu von grünen chef
robert habeck geführt werden sollen der
selbst von einfachsten wirtschafts und
finanzpolitischen zusammenhängen
nachweislich auch keine ahnung hat die
verschärfung der verantwortungslosen
klima und energiepolitik droht die
ampelkoalition deutschland endgültig ins
energiepolitische chaos zu stürzen die
ampel forciert die deindustrialisierung
deutschlands und zerstört so die
grundlagen unserer wirtschaftskraft und
damit künftiger staatseinnahmen den
kohleausstieg der auf 2.030 vorgezogen
wurde ist daher absolut unverantwortlich
gerade was die ostdeutschen reviere auch
betrifft was tausende arbeitsplätze
kosten wird sie es für unsere
energieversorgung und auch für unsere
betroffenen region eine katastrophe zu
denen droht durch den ausstieg aus der
kohleverstromung ein weiterer anstieg
der deutschen strompreise die ohnehin
die wüsten der welt sind beim ausbau der
sogenannten erneuerbaren energien und
der elektromobilität
werden die irrwege der
vorgängerregierung mit noch größerer
verbissenheit fortgesetzt das ist fatal
die energiequellen sonne und wind sind
nicht grundlastfähig und sind auch nicht
in der lage unsere moderne
industrienationen verlässlich und vor
allem auch günstig zu versorgen
stattdessen müssen umgehend die
voraussetzung für einen weiterbetrieb
der deutschen atomkraftwerke geschaffen
werden um genau diese lücke auch zu
schließen der von der ampelkoalition
wieder jeder vernunft weiter
vorangetriebene transformationsprozess
gefährdet endgültig die
versorgungssicherheit im land und die
zukunft deutschlands als
wirtschaftsstandort mit der neuen ampel
regierung gehen in deutschland
sprichwörtlich die lichter aus als
erstes wird sich die ampelkoalition an
ihrer corona politik messen lassen
müssen hier wird sich zeigen ob sie das
chaotische und panische vorgehen der
merkel-regierung fortsetzt und damit die
gesellschaft weiter spaltet oder endlich
eine verlässliche corona politik
verfolgt in dem umstand auch rechnung
trägt
das auch geimpfte und genesene das virus
weiter geben können und dass hier auch
endgültig eine abkopplung der panikmache
in deutschland von statten geht dass wir
da vernunft und besonnenheit in diesem
land früchte trägt in den aussagen zur
einwanderungspolitik hat sich die grüne
migrationsland ich auf ganzer linie
durchsetzen können und durchgesetzt die
ampel koalitionäre versprechen der
integrations industrie ein
sonderkonjunkturprogramm wollen
abgelehnten und geduldeten asylbewerbern
aufenthaltsrechte verschaffen
asylbewerber noch leichteren zugang zu
sozialleistungen gewähren und die
letzten restriktionen bei der
familienzusammenführung für personen mit
subsidiären schutz status auch noch
beseitigen deutschland wird dadurch noch
mehr als unter merkel zu migrations
magneten die lippenbekenntnisse zu einer
rückführung offensive die auch frau
merkel mal in den mund genommen hat sind
vor diesem hintergrund wirklich eine
farce es bleibt nämlich am ende kaum
noch jemand übrig der tatsächlich gehen
müsste wenn die ampel die
unvereinbarkeit von sozialstaat und
masseneinwanderung ignoriert und
wohlstand für alle grenzen für niemand
verspricht drohen deutschland wirklich
massive soziale verwerfungen
unser fazit ist dazu die ampel koalition
wird den wandel deutschlands zum
übergriffigen sozialistischen kuba
nannten staat beschleunigen der sich
anmaßt die bürger bis in den letzten
winkel ihres privatlebens zu bevormunden
aber an seinen kernaufgaben wie der
aufrechterhaltung von infrastruktur
rechtsordnung innerer und äußerer
sicherheit versagt der auftrag der sich
für die fdp fraktion aus diesem
koalitionsvertrag ergibt ist daher
eindeutig wir werden eine konsequente
und vernehmliche oppositionsarbeit
machen um zu verhindern dass die
interessen und freiheitsrechte der
bürger unter die räder der ideologie
geleiteten politik der ampel kommen
vielen dank
[Musik]
wenn hier heute nur dinge zum
koalitionsvertrag dazu haben wir auch
eingeladen zur ersten frage wir haben ja
in der aktuellen was wir im
koalitionsvertrag gesehen haben ist ihm
genau das was ich auch eingangs gesagt
wir sehen nicht dass hier rückführung
offensive überhaupt gestartet werden das
hier geduldete oder auch
migranten die hier kein bleiberecht
haben auch noch keiner weise abgeschoben
werden können das sehen wir nicht im
gegenteil hier wird wirklich der
spurwechsel dem wir immer kritisiert
haben vollzogen und das wollen wir nicht
und das wird natürlich zur sozialen
verwerfungen uns im land führen
vielen dank
auch das jetzt mein punkt wortreich und
bildreich beschrieben was er davon hält
was die koalitionäre der zukunft da
vorgelegt haben professor richter
absehbar oder ja wobei also mir schon
noch mal aufgefallen ist diese doch sehr
vernichtende kritik und diese harschen
worte und dann natürlich auch
übertreibungen die fast schon wieder so
ein bisschen in der karikatur über gehen
ja der sozialistische gouvernanten staat
also ich glaube das kann man den chor
und jetzt hier koalition den zukünftigen
koalitionspartner sich nicht irgendwie
irgendwo unterstellt also da wird
irgendwie auch ein sehr sehr
übertriebenes bild gezeichnet was
natürlich dann irgendwie auch die
bereitschaft vermissen lässt sich
wirklich und ernsthaft mit dieser
politik und mit diesem koalitionsvertrag
auseinanderzusetzen und daneben punkte
auf zugreifen wo man sagen kann hier
gibt es aber eine bessere alternative
eine bessere perspektive
das hat er ja an dieser stelle gar
nichts geleistet ja die eigene klientel
bedient man damit sicherlich ganz gut
aber an dieser stelle so vielleicht auch
schon mal der hinweis erbracht sein dass
wir gegen 17 uhr auf die reaktionen von
der union warten da sind wir gespannt
das werden wir natürlich nach hause
übertragen meine damen und herren und wo
auch immer sie jetzt gerade zuschauen
und zuhören
machen deshalb jetzt hier weiter und
schauen mal auf die beiden grünen
spitzen auf die beiden parteichefs und
diejenigen die dann jetzt auch in
ministerämter kommen werden also robert
habeck und annalena baerbock und jetzt
wissen wir schon dass robert habeck
anscheinend
eine art wirtschafts und
klimaministerium bekommen wird und
anscheinend an aussenministerin annalena
baerbock wird wie bewerten sie das
ja das ist in gewisser weise schon ein
spektakulärer schritt weil dieser neu
zuschneiden
neuzuschnitt eines ministeriums den
hatten wir so bislang auch noch nicht
also er macht sicherlich sinn das würde
ich schon sagen aber er ist an dieser
stelle wirklich an nur um und
ist ein zugeständnis an grüne politik
also das würde ich schon auch als ein
sieg der grünen sehen und mit dem
außenministerium na ja das ist natürlich
ein schwieriges amt wir wissen es aus
der vergangenheit dass sich manche
politikerinnen und politiker die eben
dafür vorgesehen waren eigentlich davor
gedrückt haben weil sie gesagt haben da
kann man keine lorbeeren ernten da kann
man nicht realisieren da kann man
wirklich nur immer wieder von jeden tag
neu an krisenbewältigung betreiben und
irgendwie die schlimmsten krisen erde
irgendwie mit deutscher hilfe
einzudämmen versuchen also das ist kein
leichter job und das ist kein amt wo man
sich gute meriten verdient und für
andere ämter
empfiehlt also insofern bin ich
überrascht dass das auch an die grünen
gehen soll aber ich denke dass wird
annalena baerbock sicherlich kompetent
machen können und
sie wird sich hineinstürzen in all diese
krieg sind werte die wir gerade in
europa aber auch in anderen stellen der
welt haben und genug sind vorhanden und
da ist wirklich dringender
entscheidungsbedarf
ja es gibt natürlich auch andere stimmen
die sagen oh je wir stellen uns jetzt
gerade vor annalena baerbock sitzt vor
herrn nachdem außenminister kollegen von
moskau das müssen wir abwarten
andererseits muss man auch sagen
außenminister sind in der bundesrepublik
deutschland immer also sehr oft auch die
beliebtesten politiker in im ranking
gewesen also auch das hat man damit in
verbindung zu bringen
das heißt allerdings auch immer wie
stark dafür ein außenminister sein wie
viel dafür selber tun und was nimmt der
kanzler oder die kanzlerin im weg was ja
was erwarten sie da beim zukünftigen
kanzler
naja olaf scholz hat ja als
finanzpolitiker zum beispiel in europa
eine ganz ganz wichtige rolle gespielt
also er ist auf der internationalen
bühne sehr bekannt und sehr
einflussreich und deutschlands rolle in
europa ist überragend das kann man nicht
anders qualifizieren in der welt
sicherlich nicht aber da ist sie eben
als deutschland als einen der chor einer
der großen wirtschaftlichen mitspieler
im weltgeschehen ist sicherlich auch
eine wichtige stimme also insofern muss
man da schon irgendwie auch profil
zeigen ob das an der lena bierbauch
gelingt weiß es nicht aber erinnern wir
uns daran dass wir schon mal einen
grünen außenminister hatten als eben
ganz viele diplomaten in der welt
entsetzt machen zu beginn man im
gesamtjahr so fischer richtig da so ist
es ja ich euch grafischer und der wurde
in der anfangsphase ja also mit
samthandschuhen angefasst und man hatte
den eindruck der kann das nicht oder hat
sich da sehr profiliert und großes
ansehen in der welt wirkt also alles ist
möglich
und insofern würde ich auch mehr
zutrauen dass sie da eine gute figur
abgibt und sich irgendwie ihr renommee
erarbeitet aber wie gesagt es ist im
moment ja alles von wirklich
dramatischen krisen bestimmt und sich
dazu profitieren ist nicht so ganz
einfach da hetzt man eigentlich nur von
krisen management zu krisenmanager aber
zwei minister wissen wir jetzt schon mal
von den grünen dankeschön für moment
professor richter wir gehen nach berlin
zur treffer mit einem gast und jetzt ist
die frage michael kellner ist der
zukünftige minister oder zukünftige
parteichef
gute frage ich wollte eigentlich nach
den länderministern erst mal fragen um
ein bisschen uns voranzubringen das
ganze nach wie vor unter zweig plus
regeln mit michael klenner dem
bundesgeschäftsführer der grünen wir
wissen von robert habeck und wir wissen
von annalena baerbock dass die ins
kabinett gehen sagen es die anderen zwei
bis drei noch
es ist total verständlich dass sie
fragen aber sehen sie bitte nach wir
haben gestern weiß ob es heute morgen
einen koalitionsvertrag verhandelt die
sehr guten koalitionsvertrag verhandelt
und wir werden jetzt im nachgang über
die besetzung fragen als vorstand
gemeinsam entscheiden dann verraten sie
uns wenigstens den zeitplan aber ab wann
wir sehen ungefähr wissen ich kann bei
der gelegenheit noch eine information ja
auch reinbringen die spd für ihre
ministerinnen und minister vermutlich
erst am vierten dezember
nennen wie sieht es bei ihnen aus wir
müssen ja vor beginn des
mitgliederbefragung des verfahrens das
tableau haben und gründe und das sollte
eigentlich morgen starten genau wir
haben morgen eine gemeinsame sitzung
auch vom bundesvorstand und parteirat
also was wir unser erweiterter vorstand
dort werden wir beraten über die uhr war
sie einleiten und morgen um 15 uhr
werden wir die urwahl starten und vorher
wären wir dann wissen wer dazu urwald
steht auch nämlich an oder das würde
sinn machen ich baue mit dass es
gemütlich stück für stück zusammen
machen wir ein bisschen allgemeiner sie
haben zwischendrin gesagt das waren so
schwere verhandlungen oder das zitat war
ungefähr zumindest in diese richtung es
gab zwischendrin auch klage aus reihen
der grünen die nicht zufrieden waren mit
dem ablauf auch mit dem wie das thema
klimaschutz behandelt wurde wenn das
alles so stimmt was wir gelesen haben wo
was ihr nun tatsächlich am schwierigsten
doch wie gesagt es war ein total
anstrengende verhandlungen als zu
anstrengend es war auch wirklich
anstrengend aber es waren auch sehr
kreativ veränderung sondern gute
verhandlung seien gründliche
verhandlungen und wir haben gemeinsam
und zwar alle drei parteien gemeinsam
ergebnis
erreicht was ich wirklich sehen lassen
kann ich freue mich natürlich besonders
als als grüner dass wir damit auf 1,5
grad fahrt sind dass wir mit den
maßnahmen die wir verankert haben in
diesen text das deutsche klimaziel über
erfüllen in den nächsten jahren wenn wir
sie alle umgesetzt bekommen und dafür
wollen wir regieren um endlich
voranzukommen den klimaschutz und ins
handeln zu kommen um uns machen zu
kommen dass wir unser versprechen im
wahlkampf und die setzen wir jetzt um
koalitionen koalitionsverträge sind ein
geben und nehmen welche bereiche
schmerzlich denn noch am meisten wo sie
sagen da hätten wir gerne mehr gehabt da
hätten wir vielleicht sogar auch gerne
deutlich mehr gehabt nun ist sind es
drei sehr unterschiedlich partei gewesen
mit sehr unterschiedlichen vorstellungen
und ich nehme mal kapitelweise im
bereich bauen haben wir uns klar
verständigt wir bauen wir haben uns klar
verständigt wir bauen
wir bauen sozial gerecht und wir bauen
auch klima schont also haben klare
vorschriften wie das ausgehen soll mit
erneuerbarer wärme diese punkte und das
ist ein zusammenspiel von sehr sehr sehr
unterschiedlichen haltung auch über die
frage wie mit mieten um geht haben wir
lange diskutiert aber ich finde es
insgesamt ein sehr guter eine sehr gute
lösung geworden die nach vorne reichen
und deswegen nicht so ein
koalitionsvertrag geworden der eine
kriegt das und schweigt zu allen anderen
der andere das am schweizer zu einem
anderen so dass den gemeinsamen prozess
gewesen der war in der tat anstrengend
aber ich bin sehr zufrieden das habe ich
schon verstanden das hat die auch vorher
tatsächlich schon verstand deswegen hab
ich ja gefragt in welchen bereichen
haben sie wenigstens das bekommen was
sie eigentlich haben wollten und was
eben noch deutlich wichtiger war als das
was sich jetzt tatsächlich dafür kriegen
welcher sektor nun ich bin insgesamt
sehr zufrieden mit dem ergebnis und na
klar wir haben name war programm macht
zudem ich voller überzeugung wo wir eine
andere steuerpolitik vorgeschlagen haben
und das war beispielsweise ein punkt das
war gemeinsam nicht möglich aber auch da
wir haben uns darauf verständigt und das
war für uns nochmal der entscheidende
punkt dass wir die fragen von
ökologischen investitionen absichern und
dass wir eben auch in den sozialen
ausgleich unserem land investieren mit
einer kindergrundsicherung mitten sofort
zuschlag beim kindergeld all das sind
punkte wo wir sagen ja wir wollen dass
unser land gerechter zugeht und dann
haben wir halt andere wege gewählt als
die ursprünglich vielleicht ein
wahlprogramm hatten also
kindergrundsicherung kinder zwischen
hatten wir im wahlprogramm ich will
sagen es sind kompromisse davon lebt
eben auch politik dass man sich auch
gemeinsam hinsetzen kann gemeinsam
gründlich verhandeln kann und dann
gemeinsam getragen das ergebnis hat das
ist ja gar nicht verwerflich hinkriege
aber man kann es ja dann auch wo ich bin
denn abschließend herr kerner
vor ihnen liegen große aufgaben ist die
drei parteien mit unterschiedlichen
kulturen auch mit unterschiedlichen
vorstellen wo sehen sie auch nach den
gesprächen die sie geführt haben die
brutal hart gewesen sind wie wir jetzt
auch noch mal gehört haben wo sehen sie
die größten risiken bei dieser koalition
total anstrengend und das zitat richtig
zu haben
aber ich glaube dass auch
unterschiedliche kulturen und
unterschiedliche haltung das kann ja
eine das kann man ist das hat man auch
in diesen gesprächen gemerkt das kann
auch eine bereicherung sein und ich
glaube es war für alle seiten durchaus
horizont erweitern sich stundenlang auch
zurück zu ringen über die
unterschiedlichen position und ich
glaube das ist ein geist der unserem
land gut tut auch im geist sich
gegenseitig zuzuhören kompromisse zu
finden lösungsvorschläge zu machen und
dann die dinge anzupacken wir sind
gespannt wie es in der praxis
funktioniert da sind wir ja noch ein
bisschen von entfernt erst mal stehen
die entscheidungen der partei noch an
sowohl bei spd und fdp aber auch eben
die die urwahl der grünen mitglieder
michael keller vielen dank dass ich noch
mal zu uns gekommen sind ich gebe zurück
zur stephan kulle in bonn und ich sage
danke schön für den moment wir sind
natürlich lange noch nicht fertig aber
danke schön erst mal dafür so wir warten
meine damen und herren das soll noch mal
verkündet 17 uhr soll es losgehen das
wäre in zwei minuten es sieht noch nicht
ganz so aus union von cdu und csu wollen
mit ihren beiden fraktionschefs vor die
kameras treten und ihre kommentierung
leisten zu dem was wir da jetzt gehört
haben bei der pressekonferenz bei der
vorstellung des koalitionsvertrags von
spd grünen und fdp und dann darf ich mal
eben gerade noch frau
ministerpräsidentin schwesig zitieren an
dieser stelle die sagte nicht mehr immer
abwarten langes abwarten und dann
plötzlich alarm machen sondern schneller
werden professor richter das ist schon
punkt also das hat man jetzt ende in der
korona krise auch gemerkt und wurden die
leute ja schon unruhig auf der straße
ist einfach passiert denn jetzt mal weiß
wie lange wollt ihr denn jetzt noch
warten und dann ist da ja immer noch
fast der erste gewesen der überhaupt
gesprungen ist und was getan hat glauben
sie dass das tatsächlich nicht
systemimmanent bei uns deutschen im gen
drin und wir können gar nicht anders
sondern dass eine andere regierung die
nicht von frau merkel angeführt wird das
tatsächlich besser hinkriegen kann
also ehrlich gesagt nein ich glaube
nicht die geschwindigkeit des regierens
wird jetzt nicht davon abhängen wer
jetzt gerade zusammen findet sondern das
sind eine reihe von faktoren die da der
rolle spielen und in der korona pandemie
ist es ja immer die diskrepanz gewesen
man erwartet von der politik schnellere
lösungen und die verbreitung des virus
ist allerdings voraus also insofern
konnte man gar nicht politisch mithalten
mit dem tempo mit dem diese pandemie
sich ausgebreitet hat das gilt auch für
andere konflikte denken wir an belarus
oder denken wir an krisen der
europäischen union wo man immer erst
einmal mit dem krisen geschehen
konfrontiert worden ist und dann erst
irgendwie nach lösungen gesucht hat also
insofern würde sagen es ist immer auch
ein wesen der politik langsam zu sein zu
behäbig aus der wahrnehmung der
öffentlichkeit
und insofern glaube ich nicht dass jetzt
diese neuen koalitionäre sind drei
partner und nicht wie bislang zwei das
heißt sie müssen sich in größerer zahl
untereinander abstimmen und koordinieren
dass die jetzt gewissermaßen ein ganz
anderes tempo des regierens an den tag
legen werden das wird weiterhin an
vielen stellen haken und es wird
probleme geben die man im moment nicht
zu lösen weiß und das ist glaube ich ein
stück des wesens der politik also sagen
diese behäbigkeit ist ein wesen der
politik für mich selber bemerkenswert
aber gerade ich möchte ja ungerne einem
professor widersprechen aber gott sei
dank ist das diplom schon und tust jetzt
mal wir haben tatsächlich in dieser in
dieser corona krise gemerkt dass man zu
lange zugewartet hat man hatte
informationen darüber dass es
beispielsweise eine britische variante
eine mutante gibt und es dauerte wochen
bis die bundesregierung mal in
irgendeiner weise regiert hat reagiert
hat glauben sie dass die menschen sich
das nicht wünschen dass es dass man ein
bisschen schneller auf kommt ja klar
also ich meine ich will das nicht so
verstanden wir sind dass ich sage wir
müssen jetzt das schlechte abschneiden
des regierens in der korona pandemie zum
maßstab aller erwartungen machen nein
also wir hätten da uns natürlich alle
viel schnellere politische reaktionen
erwünscht aber wenn man sich mal
umschaut in der welt dann gibt es kaum
einen staat der dem es gelungen ist über
schnelles reagieren die pandemie ein
wirklich massiv einzudämmen vielleicht
der einzige australien in seiner
insellage ansonsten sehen wir eben genau
das was wir auch in der deutschen
politik gesehen haben und dass politik
ist eben ein bohren dicker bretter und
das dauert und das ist kommt vielleicht
für eine pandemie geschehen zu lange
dauert zu lang und kommt dann zu spät
also insofern klar die deutsche politik
hat an vielen stellen gerade als
gesundheitspolitik massive fehler steckt
wir gehen mal ganze union herr professor
richter und wenn mal zu und haben auch
von meiner seite wobei ein guter abend
ist es nicht also wir sind zutiefst
besorgt aufgrund der korona lage und wir
sind auch der meinung dass die maßnahmen
die bislang auf den weg gebracht worden
sind aller voraussicht nach nicht
reichen werden um die vierte welle zu
brechen ist es gut und richtig dass olaf
scholz sich jetzt dazu bekannt hat das
mehr zu tun ist aber wir müssen das
jetzt möglichst schnell tun wir können
nicht warten bis die neue regierung
gebildet ist das sind die
ministerpräsidenten auch gefordert und
dementsprechend rate ich wirklich
dringend dazu auch ohne tabus und ohne
einschränkungen darüber nachzudenken das
instrumentarium was da ist um die korona
pandemie zu bekämpfen auch
vollumfänglich zu nutzen und sollten
instrumente notwendig sein die jetzt
rechtlich nicht mehr möglich sind kann
ich auch eins sagen die cdu csu
bundestagsfraktion steht jederzeit
bereit auch sehr sehr kurzfristig
veränderungen zu sorgen das gilt zum
beispiel auch für die bereits
angekündigte impfpflicht für besonders
sensitive berufe der zweite große punkt
ist natürlich dass heute der
koalitionsvertrag von der links gelben
koalition auch auf den weg gebracht
worden ist und als erstes das wird sich
vielleicht wundern aber ich denke mal
das gehört sich so und das ist ja auch
gut fürs land ist es so dass wir dieser
koalition wirklich alles alles gute
wünschen wir wünschen eine glückliche
hand bei dem was sie an schwierigen
aufgaben vor sich hat aber nach der
ersten durchsicht dieses
koalitionsvertrages sind wir natürlich
besorgt also wir erkennen nicht den
aufbruch und wir kennen auch nicht dass
eine stringente handschrift drin ist
sondern im gegenteil es ist für jeden
etwas dabei es ist sehr sehr großzügig
sehr sehr viel versprochen worden und
wir sehen nicht wie das also finanziell
untermauert ist wie das auch
gegenfinanziert werden sollen das
erfüllt uns mit großer sorge ein
weiterer bereich der uns auch mit großer
sorge erfüllt ist gerade angesichts der
ereignisse in den letzten wochen und
monaten das kapitel über die
migrationspolitik der spurwechsel die
legalisierung von illegaler migration
das nimmt dort also einen großen raum
ein und auch das werden wir wie viele
viele andere bereiche sehr genau
beobachten müssen und wir werden
natürlich eine konstruktive opposition
sein das ist überhaupt keine frage aber
da wir meinen dass dinge falsch laufen
da werden wir das auch adressieren und
insofern ist es so dass wir sicherlich
noch sehr spannende zeiten und spannende
diskussionen vor uns haben
ja sehr geehrte damen und herren
dieser koalitionsvertrag der heute
vorgestellt worden ist ist die
geburtsurkunde
einer links gelben koalition
olaf scholz hat deutlich gemacht dass er
die politik der großen wirkungen will es
ist aber deutlich geworden dass man mit
den vorgestellten bei den vorgestellten
punkten erhebliche zweifel an der
richtung haben kann und deswegen ist es
berechtigt dass man jetzt sorgen hat ob
die
herausforderungen vor denen unser land
und europa steht in diesem
koalitionspapier richtig adressiert
worden sind wir haben sorgen bei dem was
zu migration in diesem koalitionsvertrag
steht hier geht es um neue anreize und
neue pool effekte die zu erheblich mehr
an migration nach europa und deutschland
führen werden wie man damit umgeht
darüber findet man in diesem papier
leider ausgesprochen wenig aber die
perfekte werden gesetzt man kann sorgen
haben bei dem bereich der wirtschaft und
entlastung der mitte der gesellschaft
es verstecken sich steuererhöhungen in
diesem koalitionspapier
deutlich in den bereich von abschaffung
'nen sogenannte subventionen
man kann sorge haben in dem bereich
finanzen und schulden weil zahlreiche
schlupflöcher geschaffen werden in dem
koalitionspapier um in deutschland und
europa zusätzliche schulden zu
ermöglichen auch wenn wir feststellen
dass mit dem jahr 2023 ein fixpunkt
gesetzt worden ist um die schuldenbremse
wieder einzuhalten auf der anderen seite
werden erhebliche schlupflöcher eröffnet
und die bereich der gesellschaftspolitik
finden wir diesen
koalitionspapier die freigabe von
cannabis da kann man berechtigt sorge
haben was das mit unserer jungen
gesellschaft macht und das über einen
von uns mit der spd gemeinsam
intensiv beraten und ausgehandelten
kompromiss zum 219 are also zur frage
von abtreibungen jetzt dieser § 19a
komplett gestrichen werden soll zeigt
das ganz offensichtlich auch hier ein
neues geschäftliches bild was den schutz
des lebens angeht in diesem papier
aufgeschrieben ist auch da kann man sehr
große sorge haben was dies für die
zukunft bedeutet von daher ja wir
erwarten dass diese koalition
politik
mitwirkungen vollzieht allerdings noch
mal bei der richtung kann man mehr als
große zweifel haben ja und wenn man sich
anschaut noch einmal zum thema
handschrift also ich sehe da nicht den
großen wettbewerbs
wirtschaftspolitischen finanzpolitischen
wumms ich sehe da auch nicht den umwelt-
und klimapolitischen wurms was mich sehr
erstaunt die die sich durchgesetzt haben
sind die sozialdemokraten weil
sozialpolitisch ist es in ausgaben roms
der da also drin steht in diesem
regierungsprogramm in diesem
koalitionsvertrag und insofern sind wir
auch sehr gespannt wie die statik dieser
koalition in den letzten in den nächsten
monaten dann entsprechend aussehen wird
wir haben mit interesse verfolgte
die koalition die zukünftige koalition
die klimaziele der großen koalition
nicht weiter anpasst obwohl in der
vergangenheit gerade von den grünen dies
als
unambitioniert kritisiert worden ist was
wir da vereinbart haben von daher sind
wir sehr gespannt wie auch diese
koalition dann mit der erfüllung dieser
ziele umgeht wir hatten einen klaren
plan und klare richtung und deswegen es
wird sich zeigen wie diese neue
koalition dieses thema das jetzt nicht
ambitionierte gefasst hat dann auch
umsetzen will vielen dank kommen wir nun
zu ihren fragen von schweizer vom
mitteldeutschen
eine zusammenarbeit in der opposition so
zusagen geben und sind punkte drin wie
zb heizkostenzuschuss bei den
strompreisen damit der unionsfraktion
nicht zu machen waren da auch ein
bisschen der spiegel vorgehalten nein
der spiegel wird uns nicht vorgehalten
und konstruktive opposition bedeutet
dass wir natürlich auch sachen die in
diesem koalitionspapier drin stehen gut
finden das heißt die modernisierung des
staates da steht ja viel drin was also
auch ursprünglich in unserem
wahlprogramm drin stand und insofern
wären wir das natürlich sehr konstruktiv
begleiten was die digitalisierung angeht
und was auch viele felder angeht die
sonst noch zu bearbeiten sind wie
beispielsweise das thema bauen und das
schaffen von wohnraum das schaffen von
neuen flächen also es gibt durchaus eine
menge punkte die wir unterstützen aber
wir haben halt auch in vielen vielen
bereichen große sorge und das wir haben
wir adressieren und das werden wir auch
ganz unabhängig davon adressieren wer
sonst noch in der opposition ist wir
machen unser eigenes ding als cdu/csu
und da legen wir auch großen wert drauf
sind eine konstruktive opposition aber
wir sind auch eine kritische opposition
nicht plump nicht unfair aber
kritisch im rahmen des was auch eine
debatte im deutschen bundestag
erwartet und dann wird sehen wie die
vielen platzhalter in diesem
koalitionsvertrag dann wirklich mit
leben und gesetzen auch erfüllt und
gefüllt werden und deswegen wir erwarten
eine sehr intensive und
vielleicht auch manchmal muntere
auseinandersetzung im deutschen
bundestag nicht immer zu angenehmen
themen aber die herausforderung von
denen wir insgesamt stehen die sind klar
die müssen bearbeitet werden und der
wird es richtungs unterschiede geben und
da werden wir diese bundesregierung auch
zukünftig kritisch im deutschen
bundestag begleiten
und eren vielen dank für ihr interesse
dankeschön
ja das war die reaktion
natürlich deutlich an der symptome und
deutlich anders auch inhaltlich als das
was wir von der kfd vor hingehört haben
natürlich begleitet man das ganze
kritisch aber auch nicht grundsätzlich
ablehnend allerdings muss ich mal gerade
eine überschrift die die afg
notiert hat vorlesen freies for future
kritisiert koalitionsvertrag als nicht
ausreichend
auch greenpeace und grüne jugend zeigen
sich unzufrieden
herr professor richter war das auch zu
erwarten oder wundert sie das etwas na
das war ja schon im vorfeld deutlich
geworden dass die grüne basis also jetzt
nicht nur im engeren sinne die
parteimitglieder sondern auch die die
sich den grünen als jugendliche
heranwachsende nachfühlen dass die mit
einerseits überhaupt der koalitions
perspektive und zufrieden waren also die
grünen müssen dann eben kompromisse
schließen wenn sie mit zwei anderen
parteien koalieren wollen und dann in
den koalitionsverhandlungen auch
unzufriedenheit gezeigt haben weil sie
eben die klimaziele nicht richtig
behandelt sein also insofern ist das
eine durchgängige linie der kritik und
die wird sie sicherlich dann noch mal
wenn die basis die grüne basis über
diese diesen koalitionsvertrag abstimmt
nochmal artikulieren also da muss man
schon mal ein bisschen die luft anhalten
ob das alles so gut geht wie sich jetzt
die grünen verhandlungspartner das
gewünscht haben oder ob das grummeln an
der basis noch mal zu stark zunimmt dass
man irgendwie vielleicht partien dieses
koalitionsvertrags oder dann auch der
personellen besetzung noch mal infrage
gestellt kann man im moment schlecht
abschätzen also das heißt es muss ja
erstens das personaltableau abgesegnet
werden und zweitens dieses programm
dieser vertrag also sie sagen da ist
schon noch ein kritisches moment ja also
jedenfalls dass kritische unter den
allen
3 denn in der fdp wird es ja keine
mitgliederbefragung dem sinne geben also
das heißt dann muss man nicht befürchten
dass das nochmal alles irgendwie ja
kritisch beäugt und hin gar in frage
gestellt wird bei der spd würde ich das
auch nicht für wahrscheinlich halten
weil ja da die basis ist eigentlich das
mitträgt und froh ist dass die spd jetzt
in dieser führungsposition ist eben nur
bei den grünen glaube ich gibt es da
schon noch mal ein großes potenzial wenn
man das mal so sagen will das schon noch
mal
größeres gewicht erlangen kann aber
letztendlich wäre das natürlich ein
riesenschritt zu sagen wir lehnen das
alles ab und damit während gewissermaßen
alle verhandlungen geplatzt und ein
partner würde ausfallen also das wäre
die größtmögliche katastrophe die man
von der basis aus anrichten könnte und
das wird man sich glaube ich vor dem
hintergrund schon auch noch mal gut und
gründlich überlegen sondern wir niemals
nicht bleiben vorsichtig und begutachten
es dann wenn es passiert und durch ist
ganz kurz noch zum schluss und auf einem
verbunden mit einem dankeschön für ihre
einschätzung welcher zauber wohnt dem
ganzen interesse hat erlebt haben
na ja also ich habe es vorhin schon so
versucht zu formulieren das war ja so
ein bisschen inszeniert wie der
krönungsmesse ja es hat etwas sehr
feierlich ist und man weiß ich glaube
ich dass historischen moment durchaus
bewusst als dann die koalitionäre vor
die kameras traten und ihre
pressekonferenz abhielten also das ist
ein novum in der geschichte der
bundesrepublik es ist ein experiment
es zeichnet eine partei entwicklung nach
die eben für viele bundesbürgerinnen und
bundesbürger ungewöhnlich ist die aber
schon natürlich seit anderthalb zwei
jahrzehnten dreieinhalb jahrzehnten fast
irgendwie sich angekündigt hat aber es
bleibt irgendwie etwas ganz neues von
dem man noch nicht so genau weiß wie es
ausgeht was einem noch so ein bisschen
unheimlich bleibt was aber
dementsprechend auch inszeniert worden
ist als wir stellen hier was ganz neues
auf die beine
und da muss man natürlich dann mit aller
nüchternheit gucken wie das dann
wirklich aussieht und ob dieses
innovative sich auch dann in der
innovativen politik wieder niederschlägt
da bin ich sehr gespannt